good morning everyone um time being
10:05 uh I would
ask
representative sellers to lead us in the
pledge he's been
practicing pledge aliance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank
you so a couple of quick announcements
um one is on the exec session that is uh
scheduled for 1:00 um due to a number
of of circumstances most of which had to
do with um the availability of of
amendments that have been promised and
or working on and not received as yet um
we're going to
foro the exec session this
afternoon I thought they would be wild
Applause with that but I'll keep going
thank you thank you thank you it's a
little nut late now um so that would
mean that we have three hearings this
morning and then um we will move the
exec session um
virtually in its entirety as I look at
it quickly um to the 14th next week next
Wednesday um and and then once we do
that if we include the bills that we're
hearing
today that would mean we only would have
one additional bill which is the
legislative youth advisory Bill and then
we're done for this uh for the house
bills um we would be then done um
through March 14th when crossover and
then we go from there y rep
payer yes okay so the Whole World Hears
what you say thank you is it possible
that we could do the executive session
on the 14th starting at 9:00
am
um I will take that under advisement um
I think there were a couple
people um well um is how's how do those
well we usually have been doing them in
the afternoon um but
but I don't I don't know of any reason I
think there are actually a couple people
in your caucus that have difficulty for
nine or maybe even 10 that's what I was
thinking um and I'm not sure we
generally don't have a great deal of
discussion so I don't think it would be
I'll work this all through I I but I'm
I'm perfectly happy to fit in with
whatever we're doing um so I'll leave it
up to representative she and Mr chair
that was moving the exec session from
the afternoon to the morning I didn't
hear you uh yeah for we and we haven't
put it in the calendar as yet for the
14th okay um that'd be great actually we
should do that by noon time
today all right
um great suggestion great Point um let's
uh move from there um we have
three hearings today um and that almost
that does eliminate all of the hearings
we have on our house bills um and even
those are kind of uh um just uh partly
discussion today as uh as hearings uh
there will be additional information
coming on I think all of them um that
being said um I will open the hearing on
on House Bill
1030 and recognize the prime sponsor who
happens to be our vice
chair and you will need a pink
card which is kind of odd but
true and if you would bring another one
back so that I can use it for the next
committee
good morning uh representative shien um
Prime sponsor of House Bill
1030 good
morning could you please introduce
yourself for the for the
YouTube I'm representative Vanessa Shen
and I represent Hillsburg 43 the town of
Milford um HB
um I uh drafted this bill um basically
as a placeholder bill um as you know um
representative wall and I were appointed
to the special committee on commissions
by the speaker to uh look through
commissions that um are no longer needed
um and so um if you remember a couple
months ago we um passed s sp84
unanimously out of this committee with
um we replaced all of the original
language of s sp84 uh with amendments
that would um Sunset some of the
Committees that we found were inactive
um in that special committee on
commissions as well as a a couple other
amendments that we were asked to place
in the bill by legislative
Services um and that sb84 passed our
house and is now in the other body
waiting to be acted on and it hasn't yet
so we would like to um draft an
amendment um to 10:30 replacing all with
the same language we just passed s sp84
with all of that language being um put
into 10:30 passing it again out of the
house sending it over to the other body
just in
case um so that's the plan with um HP
1030 and I'd be happy to take
questions thank you um are there
questions I I can I can help explain
some of the process maybe for um our
newer members so um SB
84 when the house um amended
sb84 um we send it back um amended and
and the Senate has the option of
concurring non-c concurring or um asking
for a committee of
conference they take those up as house
messages that come to the Senate um as
yet they have not taken up that message
um so we really don't know um and I'm to
be honest I'm not sure completely of
Senate rules uh they may have the
ability within their rules um to not
take it up at all and and in that case
it would die on the table
um by doing the process that
representative Sheen mentions by loading
it onto or the language onto this house
bill on in and passing it in the Full
House it would then go over during
crossover as a as a house bill and it
would have to be assigned to one of the
Senate committees so it would actually
Force getting a hearing um in the Senate
where where the other process um it may
not get that that attention so that
hopefully um alleviates some of the
questions you have but if there are
further questions
uh seeing none I think you're
yeah representative
Hobson thank you for taking my question
um I'm a little confused as to why oh
yeah I'm confused as to why it wouldn't
be taken up by the other body if we sent
it over
there do do you know what I'm saying
what I don't know what their reasonings
would
be um
not many not many of us know the the
inner workings of uh the body on the
other side of the wall
um you know sometimes it's asking uh the
unknowable further questions seeing none
thank you
representative I have no other pink
cards um for this bill and uh there's no
good asking if anyone in the audience
has further questions um so uh with that
um we'll close the hearing on House Bill
10:30
um the next hearing is due for
10:30 um we expected much more
conversation so uh you've got 10 minutes
to stretch thanks very
much
it is 10:35 and I'd like to open up the
hearing for HB
1388 and um representative Hill welcome
to ledge
Administration thank you madam chair um
it's always a pleasure to be at
legislative
Administration no really it is um could
you please introduce yourself so we
know who you represent thank
you good morning everyone I am
representative Greg Hill um I serve the
community of Northfield which is marac 2
um I'm here uh this morning to discuss
with you um House Bill and introduce
House Bill
1388 um it may
look uh that bill may look very um
familiar to you because it is the bill
that um we put forth last uh
January as a retain bill um to House
Bill
301 um in in in its entirety
um what I'm proposing to you or let me
just back up a second the reason um that
house bill 301 was tabled um in January
was at my request
um we had had conversations with members
of the Ethics Committee about House Bill
301 and they pointed out some very good
things uh that that they were
uncomfortable with Andor language that
they would like to have changed so at
that time we had one of two options we
could have um passed House Bill
301 and um worked on an amendment that
would be brought to the Senate um Andor
we could have worked on a fast Amendment
and brought it to the floor as a floor
Amendment um in the
house it was our judgment um that that
kind of a conversation um on something
is important as um our our ethics um
guidelines and laws was too important to
try to have a conversation on the floor
of the house um and we also recognized
that we had the opportunity because
legislative Administration was holding
um House Bill 1388 we had the ability to
amend House Bill
1388 in any way we we wanted and bring
the actual bill after it passes the
house floor to the senate in a um in a
joint venture with the house house
Ethics Committee so that was the route
we took um we we tabled House Bill 301
and then we um sat back down with the
Ethics Committee people and um one of
which is on our committee um now and um
and we hammered out U where differences
were were uh we talked about language um
and it turned out that we were um
working
in pretty similar lines we just had
different ways of getting to the to the
same spot so what you have in front of
you right
now um are two options and I've labeled
them purposely um option A and option b
without um anyone knowing except for for
me um which is which and what I would
ask the committee is for them to um or
for you to um consider the two of them
and decide which of those would be um
more understandable more readable more
um more given the ability to follow um
by your colleagues and yourselves
so um we will not uh my understanding is
we will not be executing that bill today
um and so this would be something that
you can uh Ponder or consider for the
next week or so um and and one of these
these both these options you'll notice
they're not in the form of amendments as
yet they will be converted to amendments
and brought back to the committee uh
prior to the executive session so any
changes uh that you see um can be made
prior to going for amendments um but I
should just point out um the really the
two areas that
uh that are different um and one
is the idea um
of including um the the phrase or the
two words special interest interest
um special interest is a um well
um is defined in our current ethics book
and um it means according to this
definition here any Financial or
non-financial personal
interest um and it's under the
definition of conflict of interest so a
conflict of interest is a special
interest and it means any Financial or
non-financial personal interest that's
what one option A has option b simply
goes from
um conflict of interest definition and
says a conflict of interest means any
Financial or non-financial personal
interest so it it deletes the phrase
special interest
entirely the only other change or the
only other um point of difference is
um I have to find it um in the
exceptions for recusal for conflict of
interest um and it's a percentage change
so one of them requires that if a
legislator or the legislator's household
members ownership of
Securities um is um less than
1% than you're exempt the other says if
it's
5% you're exempt um and the reason that
those to exist is
um you know all of us I think it's fair
to say hold some kind of um um
retirement income whether it's in a
Company pension whether it's in our own
mutual funds whether it's on our own
IRAs anything like that um it was and
this didn't exist by the way in our um
House Bill 301 the original one so this
is one of the things that we held that
up for purposely but the question is at
what level does that um do you need to
own some percentage of um of the
outstanding shares of a mutual fund or
of an underlying company um before you
would um it would be subject to a
conflict of Interest gets a little
technical
um that's but that's really the only two
differences between option A and option
b
um I think with that I'll end my
testimony I'm happy to answer any
questions um that may come up but
certainly um I want to make sure
everyone understands that uh this is
only
um sections three and four
um
of of multi-art um P section in your in
your booklet um but these are the only
places that this bill is dealing with
and uh and these are the only places
that there were differences between what
the health Ethics Committee wanted and
what um I as a representative of the
legislative Administration wanted so
just that's where it
sits are there any questions from the
committee rep
sellers thank you madam chair um my
question is option A and option b and
I'm not sure I can even ask this
question of you but I'm going to ask it
and you can just say no do you prefer
one or the
other
um no I don't um they do I I would be
happy with either um and that was the
interesting part and I'm happy to that
you asked the question
um as much as it pained me to table
House Bill
301 um because it was presented to me
that there were wide differences with
with how the Ethics Committee was
looking at
301 and then once we tabled it and we
sat down and hammered out line by line
turned out we were very close um and I
think that surprised the Ethics
Committee people as much as it did me um
or maybe more so so um so at this point
I really don't have a preference
um I think and I agree with the original
sponsors of 301 and the prior two
iterations before that that came from
the chair of Ethics Committee um this is
we've not had recusal in our guidelines
prior to this and um I think it's fair
to say we have all seen circumstances
where that make it imperative that we do
address so um both of these will
accomplish that
longwinded answer to saying yes
but representative
mcarter thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question does this um I I
obviously don't have hb31 in its
entirety in front of me but does this uh
eliminate the uh ability for someone to
just declare their intent to
vote on a particular issue
anyway they this is this is this saying
that they must recuse regardless of um
their intent being noticed I'm not sure
I understand that process sure um so
this is only
dealing this is only dealing with those
with a conflict of interest um and this
is only dealing with conflicts of
interest when there is a either a
financial or
non-financial um
conflict if if you have those one of
those and they're clear clearly defined
which um which category it is either F
Financial or non-financial um it does
say shall so you shall
um um recuse in that case does that
answer your question okay thank you and
r mcarter um HB
1388 is the language of
hb31 so if you wanted to read the full
uh all the language it's right
there any other
questions rip Hopson yeah thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question it seems as if on option
b non-financial personal interest on the
back side
really
outlines the me uh exists when a
legislator or household member has a
responsibility for the welfare of an
organization that's pretty
descriptive less uh more so than I feel
this has been in the past in other words
I think it outlines that there is a
responsibility there so am I reading
that right if it feels as if some things
that I might have questioned before are
are not a question now because I might
not be responsible for the welfare of an
organization do I have that
right uh thank you for your question um
first let me point out that that
language is the same in both
options um option A has it um on on the
second page on the back of that um at
the top under B
right um and what it gets to um and I'm
kind of glad we didn't use the phrase
fiduciary responsibility but but that's
what um that
responsibility is getting to um when
when you are part of an organization and
you have you're an officer or you have
um responsibility for um the finances
the and that's what they're getting to
with with welfare if you if you're more
than just a member of um you know the
Elks um not to pick on one organization
or another but if you are an officer of
the Elks you have direction of of how
the Elks
operate and that's what this is getting
to um it wouldn't be if you were just um
you know a card carrying member of
uh any
organization does that
help I have a followup
um
so uh responsibility for the
welfare or welfare of an organization or
the
outcome is I'm trying to establish a
relationship between that term and
advocating it seems that there are two
different
uh definitions I guess two different
scenarios um so do I do I have that
right and yes we as Representatives um
occasionally have passions and things
that we advocate for but there that's
not necessarily the
responsibility for the welfare outcome
of a welfare for an organization that
boy did I mess that up but you get where
I'm
[Laughter]
going yes you have that it it is it's
not um simply being a member the the the
point here in both is that
you're you're not uh you wouldn't have a
conflict simply being a member um you
would you would have to have more than
that level you would have to be um again
an officer uh or someone that deals with
the finances of that organization
something like that R
costable uh thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking the question um I
don't know if you it was not the way I'm
reading that is that fiduciary I mean
fiduciary is in the it is in the
paragraph the way I read it is the
welfare of the organization is tied to
by virtue of holding a fiduciary
position so if you have no fiduciary
responsibilities then you're not covered
under non-financial interest am I
getting that correct yes you
are and you said it much better than I
did
so R Pearson thank you thank you madam
chair
the just making sure okay they're in
both option A and option b both use the
term official legislative activity
can you help us out with the definition
of that um I think that is an original
language um actually um I think if you
have
your um purple book with you um there's
a there's an actual definition in there
um I think um
rudimentary I could just say that it's
uh any of the
legislative activities that we normally
do here as representatives and across
the wall as Senators um voting um
submitting legislation talking about
legislation debating um anything that a
legislator would normally do go ahead
thank you madam chair so uh this would
be ran numeral 11 on page three for
those following in their himels the
official activities are activities which
relate to official responsibilities
including the introduction of
legislation
testifying before any legislative
committee or state agency voting in
committee or in House and Senate session
or otherwise participating in
influencing influencing or attempting to
influence any decision of the
legislature
so then we have as a legislator then you
are surren
rendering your rights as a citizen of
the state to even
testify on a bill if I'm reading this do
is that am I reading this
correctly um you may be reading it
correctly thank you for your question um
I think you're word smithing it
differently than I would um
it again this um this ethics
is
dealing with us and how we operate
ourselves and how we are perceived um
and by the public so so rather than
saying we're surrendering um I think I
would be saying um we are
agreeing that um we need to hold
ourselves uh to a different standard
than surrender
in any other questions rep
costable um thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking a question um do
you have a preference on the percentages
for ownership and on on the stocks
because um on one hand 1% sounds like a
small number but 1% of a publicly traded
large larger company is a tremendous
amount of ownership in terms of a
publicly traded company at the same time
there are some publicly traded companies
that are very small or or very like
one% seems to me versus five 5% seems
too much to
me you could have 3% ownership and that
could be very substantial for a company
um do you have um have you thought about
this is at all or or are the percentages
and um I think it's fair to say I've
thought about this
um I uh in my in my real life um I am a
u a financial advisor Andor
um pension specialist um number of
things uh the 5% number does arrive does
come number of times and a number of
places in in federal law um for instance
um if you're trying to uh determine if
someone is a um key employee of an
organization of a of a company um 5% is
the number that the IRS uses as if
you're 5% owner then you are deemed um a
highly compensated individual regardless
of your compensation so I guess um
I your point is is correct that um
depending on the organization 1% or 5%
can can vary tremendously but um I think
one of these is just by using common
common numbers that are used in other
areas of finance and and
um you could say that it's arbitrary or
it's based on just a feeling I I I think
you can argue either
way R Pearson thank you madam chair and
thank you representative Hill
for taking the gauntlet here um by
virtue of office and I think that holds
true for all of us we are County
delegation folks
right as well I am but I sit on the
Executive Board of rocking Camp
County does do I now have a situation
where if we're
making or we're dealing with legislation
that involves counties or monies being
dispersed to counties because I sit on
the Executive Board of the
county as part of the county delegation
do I now have to under this recuse
myself from County
operations when it comes to State
legislation because the state does do a
lot of funding for
counties I'm not just a member of the
Rockingham County like hops but I'm
actually on the executive
board I understand
um I'm
not I would uh I guess I would answer
that two ways one is um as my personal
belief
um but understand that I am
not um going to say that my personal
beliefs will 100% align with um any
requests that you may or may not make to
the Ethics Committee for a ruling um so
that the there are certainly going to be
circumstances where someone needs to
have clarified their their individual
position um this is not meant to be a
um uh the lipus test that um that an
individual rep may may decide if there
are circumstances like that it it may be
that we do need to have um um the Ethics
Committee Rule and and you've seen any
number of those that are printed in the
calendar um but my personal belief
is even though you on the executive
committee um and your name is on the
county budget um with a
signature I would say
that you're
acting um almost as the
um the
signature to what the county delegates
are doing so you're taking their
information and and you're signing off
on it as the executive committee you're
not specifically making the budget for
um for the county I I I I'd have to
think this through I mean I but that's
my knee-jerk reaction I'm not
sure
um and and I will be frank with you that
while we were doing the language here we
weren't anticipating
other govern government
um agencies monopolies um that that we
deal with like County we were more
concerned with someone that worked for
an organiz a private or nonprofit um
organization rather than another
government um I do think that um someone
from ethics may be coming up after me I
don't know if there's a pink card or not
but um that may be a better place to ask
that question I'm not sure um but that
would be my personal
belief any other
questions thank you thank you more to
comments and do we have any other
speakers on HB
1388 seeing none I will close the
hearing for House Bill
they
oh
good morning um welcome to legislative
Administration and a hearing on House
Bill
FN um time being
11:05 I would recognize the prime
sponsor representative yo Kell thank you
chair and members of legislative
Administration committee um I am here
today to introd HB can I interrupt for a
second can you please introduce yourself
for the you membership thanks um my name
is representative Josh yella I represent
the uh District of Rockingham 32
representing Freemont Danville and
Brentwood and um it's my first time uh
in this uh presenting to this committee
so uh that's a pleasure um welcome thank
you um
so I'm here uh to introduce HB
um and I want to start off with uh that
the government is here to serve the
people the people have the right to free
speech governments do not governments
are Servants of the people and when
people want change the government should
be able to give facts about the impact
of change but not Advocate one way or
the other lobbying with taxpayer money
is compelled speech the Supreme Court
has held that violation uh that it's a
violation of your first amendment rights
to for the government to make you say
something that you don't want to say
however what I am forced and we all are
forced to fun is someone to say
something that you may not agree
with um for examp like Jehovah's
Witnesses do not Lobby vote for
political parties or candidates or run
for go government office or participate
in any action to change government uh
for religious reasons and their taxes
are used to fund speech they oppose so
in so in addition to a violation of free
speech this is a violation of their
exercise of religion by allowing this to
continue this uh this bill is just
taking the current language that I
passed out to you since this is a
complete replace of that that language
is taking that current language getting
rid of the loopholes and giving it some
teeth I have um heard some
concerns about the bill like um nhma is
is giving a valuable resource of
information however nhma still could
come to give uh information about the
impacts it would just have to withhold
whe uh their opinion about whether we
should support or oppose such
legislation unless they segregate the
money that they wanted to use for
lobbying from uh from other taxpayer
money and that that could be from
sources like their trainings where you
pay additional fee to go to their
training that is in taxpayer money that
is um fee for service right and so they
could use that money for lobbying or
they could have whole a bake sale or any
other uh way to to gather money other
than taxpayer you know uh forced
contributions um and and I have been a
part of those um nhma policy setting
committee and advocated for them to not
oppose legislation created to limit
municipalities from violating
constitutional rights and the response
is other groups uh advocate for the
protection of Rights we are here to
advocate for the
municipalities interest they advocate
for the power to Institute rent control
in in Municipal County government
committee uh they they advocate for to
allow those municipalities to
discriminate based on familial status um
in some of the recent bills in my
committee um there are many cases of
Municipal overreach from
municipalities um passing an ordinance
that says that if you want to be a
tattoo artist in in their town that you
have to be a licensed medical
doctor there is um they also there is a
t town in this state that um would give
children a 250 or $275 fine for feeding
or chasing water foul like on the beach
that's that's what that's what we
want and and then also they do stuff
like forbidding carrying around o
unopened alcoholic beverages on any
Street sidewalk alley public or
semi-public parking lot or any public
space because they're just bad at
writing laws because they forgot to
limit it to only open
containers as we sit in this committee
room today lobbying as the as the law
that I passed out with State money is
not allowed in fact most if not all
municipalities receive state money
whether that be education trust funds or
Highwood block grants or meals and rooms
tax and according to RSA 155
currently they are not allowed to lobby
with that money and if they don't
segregate that money from their other
money in a separate bank account not
just on their books all of that money
then counts as state money and they're
not allowed to use any of it for
lobbying
so I reached out to my Town
Administrator and verified that they're
not segregating their their money that
they receive from the state for money
that they can use for lobbying and money
that they can't use for lobbying so I
believe that all the municipalities I
think that it's common practice and I
think that all municipalities think that
they're Above This
law I think that all the municipalities
are in violation of the current RSA 155
and I sent out I pass around a a letter
that I'm going to be giving to the
attorney
general for to to have the Attorney
General investigate every single
municipality and and find out if they
are segregating their funds as required
by this law because as you as I got a
letter from my municipality saying that
they're they one of the reasons why they
want to be able to uh donate to HMA nhma
is that they want Advocate advocacy
services at the State House they want
lobbying as part of their dues it's not
not just um for training it's not just
for Legal Services they want lobbying
and that is a violation of their law if
they're not currently in compliance and
so I'm going to be sending that request
over to the AG's office after this
testimony today and I think that this
law that I'm putting in like if they are
found to be in non-compliance all the AG
will do is say cease and desist just
send them a letter what I believe that
they should be doing uh is not doing any
of that with any of the the taxpayer fun
money not just the money that they got
from the state and so I I want this law
this law will be clear that it's it's
going to be applying to them and and
then also it imposes penalties if they
don't comply it's not just going to be a
letter they're actually going to be
charged with the crime for for misusing
the taxpayers money for things that
they're not allowed to be doing and so
for that reason I hope that you will
join me in supporting hb1
1479 and I am open to any
questions I'm going to bet that there
are one or two um thank you for your
testimony um do I see hands for
questions from the
committee representative
sers thank you Mr chair uh thanks for
taking my question so and and part of
the section 155 you're pointed out in
state funds I might be confused that's
why I'm asking State funds and Municipal
aren't they two separate things thank
you for the
question um State funds I've I've asked
nhma before about why they or do they
segregate and they said no because they
don't receive any state funds however if
you look at um 155 Roman 2 that if they
want to use state fund or other funds
that are not State funds they have to be
in a separate bank account and so once
you put them into the same bank account
they essentially all tainted as state
funds so if the municipalities do not
currently have separate funds all their
money becomes State funds according to
this the current law on the books and
they're not allowed to use any of that
for lobbying and so um that is the basis
of my my concern today thank you for the
question further questions I have one
for you um can you do you have an
opinion of
whether this
legislation and perhaps even
um what but specifically on your on your
legislation should it be in a different
section of law um and the reason I'm
asking I guess is whether this seems to
be a pro ition on the lobby it's in the
lobbyist section
155 is it not more or would it not be
better placed in in the cities and towns
um sections because it's a Prohibition
on the cities and towns and what they
can do rather than what the lobbyists
can
do thank you for the question I think
that
um the lobby section actually kind of
makes sense because when the person
um first of all in in paragraph two it
um
it uh I thought it ref
references this
um
the um I thought it
referenced like this paragraph parag no
maybe it doesn't um I think that I think
that when the person is coming to Lobby
they they are the one that could be
creating the violation right so if the
town pays someone and hires them and
they have to go register as a lobbyist
and then they see this
law and they will say wait a minute I
just got paid from a municipality or I
just got paid this money is coming from
somewhere else that is where they would
be like hey I could be in violation
because you're not really in violation
until you come and Lobby right uh
I'm giving myself a followup
um so um how would the lobbyist know
whether the money came from the bake
sale um thank you representative Pearson
for
confirmation um I think
that's I I think that's a fair question
um I'm it's really a technical Point
more than anything else it's it's just a
an observation I wonder whether you
contemplated putting it in uh or filing
it in I did not because the it because
we're essentially uh I use a lot of the
language in my bill um from the current
155 right and and so obviously
conflicting statute so I would have to
repeal it and put it in a different
section and so um that was I think
outside the scope of what I was in y I
appreciate your answer um further
questions is representative
Kierney thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'm also selectman
sure in the town I live in I have a
fiduciary responsibility to the
taxpayers in that town not to waste
their money
nhma gives me legal advice for a minor
fee I believe of around $1,200 a year
any amount of questions I want to ask if
I have to go to the town attorney it's
$300 to $600 an hour so I'm going to get
anywhere from four two to four hours
that's it and then I'm paying more money
that is not showing a fiduciary
responsibility to the taxpayers that's
charging them for asking reasonable
questions nhma does it for
free thank you I as a
I I I would I would believe that
as I would believe that as a as a budget
Committee Member and a zba member in my
town that I have reached out for
nha's legal advice but that is not
lobbying so that's not within the scope
of this bill if if nhma sto lobbying
today they would still be able to give
you those
Services whether or not this this bill
passed so that's that's you know
information is not that barred by this
so that that's kind of outside of the
scope of this as being influenced by
this legislation have a followup
question
yeah how would I track all the bills
going through the house or the Senate
and HMA does that for
me even as a member I can't track all
the bills going through that does this
one pertain to a town does this one have
an impact on a Town they're going
through dozens of committees up
here thank you for the question um once
again that that information that they
give to the towns about interested bills
that they would be is not lobbying
that's just providing information it's
when they come up here and say kill this
bill don't vote for that bill vote for
that bill that is what lobbying is so
they they would still be able to provide
updates you know monthly updates or
whatever um as they do from time to time
as far as definitely when legis ative
session is over and the Law changes they
would still be able to do those updates
so thank you for the question further
questions representative
sellers thank you Mr chair so I know
we're picking on
NH because as an example yeah um since
we're using them can you tell me is nhma
free and how do they deter if not how do
they do you know how they deter
I do have a pin card from
NH I just ask yeah is it free it's not
and it's based on your population so
less population less
money further
questions I have another one sure
um section four uh I'm sorry section
five Roman 5 says not withstanding any
other provision of law any person who
knowingly
authorized who who is that person um is
that the selectman is that the Town
Administrator is that someone else how
how would that be determined and who
decides who's paying the
fee sorry thank you for the question um
I believe that the the
person where responsible would be the
Selectmen they are they uh get a notice
of all kind of the checks that are going
to be uh written and they approve that
you know and so I think it's the
governing body not necessarily the
select board depending on governing body
of the town would be the responsible
party so if it's a threepers select
board and one doesn't vote for it is
that person not liable is that how that
would
work
thank you for the question um if they
refrain from voting for it I would
believe that they're not culpable yeah
but I think that the pro the you know
the select board kind of makes an action
all as a collective body or not right so
so you uh thank you I think it would be
the person that literally signed the
like authorized the signing of the check
yeah or or sign the
check if the if that is not the
governing body then it would be the
person signing the check would be the
responsible person right
okay representative sellers thank you Mr
J We're not trying to make this a
conversation by the way too so y but
that I'm leading up what you were saying
there because it's interesting because
if I was uh one of the fathers or
mothers there at the town running the
town once I hand that money over to that
uh company that might be helping us like
nhma sure I'm thinking to help for me in
the town as far as legal advice and
whatnot right um if they separate or
don't separate I have no clue so the
punishment shouldn't be on me should it
should be on the uh nhma or the one that
receives the money for not well the the
thank you for the question um if you're
not if you're not per Contracting
Services for
lobbying then you would just be um doing
a uh
appropriation and they would be the
responsible party for receiving an
appropriation of State money right so
they have the same responsibility once
they're receiving that state
money representative
pay hello good morning I'm just curious
could you just tell briefly tell us the
why why did you bring this bill forward
I'm just curious of why why yeah why
what's
your because I think it's that it's um
you know whether the examples that I
gave um that I found that it was
unreasonable that this the city or the
town actually in this example um made a
request or or made this regulation that
that tattoo artists be medical doctors I
think that's inappropriate and I would
like to um
advocate for restrictions so that they
can't abuse their power and I believe
that I should not have to pay for
funding my opposition which will come
out and say no they you know it was an
honest mistake or or whatever the reason
is we should be able to have just um un
unlimited power at the municipality and
I don't want that advocated using my
money so I and and I'm sure you will
hear some testimony today from people
that don't want their money advocating
for things that they oppose
also so thank
you um last one I promise um public
funds no public funds
um you mentioned the bake sale um does
the bake sale become public funds once
it's in the public once it's in the
coffers of the town or the
municipality this this is talking about
in Roman uh two or is it I was um no
public funds shall be used and it
defines public funds as a grant or
appropriation um so
only only money that comes through
taxation um does it does it not apply to
fees or um dog licenses or um bake sales
does that not apply thank you for the
question I was um and and the
opportunity to clarify when I was making
that example I was giving the example
that nhma could still Lobby if they held
a bake sale they aren't tax tax they
aren't the government right um or or if
they did a training which they do and
and you sometimes have to pay for that
service right those monies would not be
coming from the tax for from taxpayer
right I apologize I misunderstood um
but but getting back to my question are
public funds do they become public funds
as soon as they're in the coffers of the
so the thank you thank you for yeah
making making the opportunity for me to
to clarify that yeah so this just like
the state right now all money is not
allowed to be used for for lobbying
municip this would also apply to
counties and and local municipalities
none of their money can be used for
lobbying it's for those other groups
that may get an appropriation that want
to still be able to Lobby let's say the
the um let's say the town's clerks
Association to pick just pick a
different one um they want to Lobby they
get some money from the state they do
some
trainings right and they have that money
in a separate bucket that they can then
use that money for lobbying right and so
that would be the example but no State
money it would just they could just come
and give information
as a member of that that municipality
and not
Lobby thank you we have lots of pin
cards and
it's okay
sure for the trainings for anybody yep
what money do you think is paying for
that it's all tax dollars all of it
question in there yeah I said whose
money is it okay thank thank you for the
question um
the there are the trainings are for for
different um some municipalities May um
be paying for the trainings but you it's
not required under you know statute that
they be paid for by the state so
that's and and and they're not for for
uh you know lobbying there for trainings
so thanks very much um I think I think
we're good appreciate you introducing
the Bill thank you very
much uh
chair would
call uh representative uh Keith aan
please welcome to legislative
Administration
representative
I see some friendly faces here good
morning they're all friendly faces uh
for the for the record my name is Keith
Ammon uh I live in New Boston I
represent New Boston line bro and Mount
Vernon and it's Hillsboro District 42
I'm a co-sponsor on this bill um I won't
repeat uh any of many of the points that
uh representative yella mentioned um I
do want to say that I find the compelled
speech argument very uh compelling to to
reuse the word um that that people are
being people are paying taxes for
lobbying efforts that that sometimes and
oftentimes uh work against individual
taxpayers interests and I think that is
probably the Crux of this bill
um if you you live in a town or a city
that town has many departments right it
has a select board or a board of
alderman
planning board uh school board on and on
and on it goes every one of those uh
departments in your municipality has an
association uh that they pay dues into
using taxpayer money those associations
all cluster within about a mile from
here in what used to be called The Local
Government Center if you've ever
strolled through that hallway in that
building there's offices after offices
after offices of all of these
associations they're all clustered in in
one spot for the most part and you know
I find that interesting that it's it's
basically an industry that's popped up
around uh dues from these different town
mun Municipal
departments uh sometimes in the millions
of dollars collectively across the state
and they send their lobbyists here to
the different committees that we serve
on for $100 a year that's what we get
paid uh and these people get paid maybe
$60,000 a year $80,000 a year to come
and Lobby for particular
positions that their their Association
uh
takes it's gotten to the
point when you submit a bill to OS to
office of legislative
Services OS will send that bill the
pre-draft of that bill to some of these
associations they get to weigh in on the
fiscal
note they get to put their finger on the
scale Before the bill is even
released they're treated as if they're
part of the government and they're not
they're private
organizations um an institution the
prime directive of every institution is
to perpetuate
itself so these institutions these
entities may do good
work they they may serve a useful
function but they're not entirely unself
interested they have their own
self-interest to perpetuate to grow
their membership grow their influence
and they're doing it for a large part
with taxpayer money the questions
earlier about trainings Information
Tracking bills none of that's lobbying
they can still do that they can still
they can still provide your help you
with your
fiduciary responsibilities as as a
selectman um they can provide you with
information it's when they put on the
orange badge and they come to our
committee rooms and they they don't have
when when a department head comes before
you they usually say we take no position
on this bill but we have some questions
right they don't do that they they take
a
position uh and they advocate for a
position and they're doing it with
taxpayer money so the people on the
other side of their position the people
who oppose their position are being
forced to fund their own adversaries and
I think there's an issue with that so
that that's my contribution to the
conversation thank you for hearing the
Bill thank you
um you will take
questions um representative
Cal thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
would you still be in favor of this bill
if say we amended maybe we have
questions on the um enforcement part of
the the penalties and you know lessen
the penalties or maybe even eliminated
the penalties would you be in favor of
that bill is it still a net positive
there or do we need do we need the
penalties so we can always increase
penalties at a future date if there's an
issue I I would say look at the current
legis the current RSA that
representative yella referenced and sort
of match what is happening already with
with uh you know whatever enforcement is
currently in the
statute that would be my
suggestion representative
hubson thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um could you
repeat the statistic that you just
mentioned about OS sending off was it
lsrs and is it before they are released
to the public before they're released to
the committee yeah it's happened to be
on several occasions recently and this
is kind of a new phenomenon as far as my
experience you put in a bill it may it
may have an implication for
municipalities uh or some other schools
or whatever it is right
and the association the private
Association that is not part of the
government is treated as if it's a
department of the state and they get to
write up a fiscal note it's attached to
the bill that everyone reads and it's it
puts their finger on the
scale uh no other group gets that kind
of uh you know Advanced uh you know
weight added to their opinion and and I
find that kind of uh offensive
good should that
um should that be a separate
bill where where fiscal notes um go to
I'm giving you an example of so I'm
focusing on lobbying that's what this
bill's about I understand so what what
other lobbyist gets to write their
opinion into the fiscal note that's
attached the bill and circulated to
everyone that reads it like there there
isn't another so uh it it maybe maybe
that would be a separate bill I this was
just a conversation between you and I no
one else was listening it was just about
whether there should be a separate bill
we'll have to put that one in yeah all
right thank you uh representative sers
Sor first thank you Mr chair so and I'm
going back to represent representative
hopson's point of view OLS I thought
those are supposed to be private and not
insecure and not given out at all I know
the bill or the LSR itself but even the
fiscal note would indicate that hey this
is a bill that's
happening have you actually seen this
have you absolutely seen it this term on
my
bill okay so so I think I think the the
way it works is you have to request as a
when you file as a legislator you have
to request that the bill remain private
I think you have to take that action so
and I did not do that
but done representative
uh payer sorry thank you um I would just
would like to see if you had an opinion
about um we've received this committee
has received many letters of from
various towns throughout New Hampshire
Claremont um from Council City councils
slackman boards Town
managers Salem for example Claremont for
example and a bunch of other towns um
and they are in opposition of this bill
um do you have any could you give a
brief opinion or whatnot as to why a all
these towns would be in opposition of
your bill how many towns did you did you
hear from can I ask a
question
would so why would I imagine that I
think maybe uh some uh dust has been
stirred to have them write those letters
that that would be my specul
okay I think uh we're out of questions
thanks very much
representative um chair would chair is
going to um suggest to people um we have
quite a few pink cards as you can see um
we have lunch in there somewhere um I
just would like to suggest to people
that it would be best for all of us if
you have if the prior speakers have said
something that you agree with you merely
say that you agree with um rather than
um telling us the same thing over and
over again it would be great if we had
new information when we came um my only
caution well so far um chair would call
Jennifer Pike uh who asked for three
minutes it would be great if it was
less supports the bill welcome to
legislative Administration if you could
introduce yourself it would be
great good
morning thank
you thank you for the opportunity
um my name is Jennifer Pike and I am
from New
London um and I have a 19-year-old son
with multiple complex
disabilities and I would like to speak
to
how the how this
impacts um families with
disabilities
and the poverty industry that it
creates um all of the agencies that
these
lobbyists uh
represent
um you know have a
financial
um in you know uh
input
um uh or AI a financial Financial reason
for
um uh wanting our
business um and there's a lot to gain
from our families
financially um
and unfortunately what they are doing
is with all of the
agencies surrounding our families with
disabil ities in particular as they are
um keeping our families in
poverty um because that is what benefits
all of our all of these
agencies and so um these lobbyists are
not interested in what is beneficial to
the families per se they are interested
what in what is beneficial to them um
you know Financial
speaking so um you know they will sit
there and they will say that they are
fighting for families with
disabilities um all the time but they
are not they are looking at the bottom
line uh for their
agencies so um there are many people
that
are
on different
committees that um should not be
there because
of um
different conflicts um very severe
conflicts of interests
um and
uh you know our um our privy to
information that um and and have
power um again that
to make decisions for
families
um that is just again
keeping all of us basically locked in
this poverty
situation um most of which are
single single Le families like single
moms with kids with
disabilities um and what I can suggest
to you um just so I don't have to go on
and on um is if you want to get more
information about it you can um read
there's
um uh several books or few books on this
and several books on it but um if you
want to refer to the poverty
industry um by
Daniel um
Hatcher
uh it is very well outlined but it's um
it's all about
the the monies that are going
to all of the everywhere except for the
families that need them great and the
inflated salaries that are obscene so uh
except ours um so
would you be uh willing to take
questions yes
please uh representative sers yeah thank
you for taking my uh thank you Mr chair
thank for taking my question the I think
you brought up the ethical issues in
towns it's probably anyways have you
actually seen like uh a conflict in that
area yourself personally or this is
something been told to you oh no I have
I have seen it I have EXP experienced it
I have walked it I have um it
also um in addition to the in addition
to the being locked into the poverty
industry um it expands to um all of the
programs that are created that you know
all of these wonderful programs that are
available for everyone across the state
and I apologize for the little bit of
sarcasm
um you know there's
there's you know hundreds of programs
that are
available um but
when you know in reality when you go to
access these
programs they aren't
available um so you are turned
away um you are too complicated you um
they there there are are so many reasons
um why you cannot access these
programs um they just are not available
and I would really love to know why or
where these millions of dollars um are
really going I mean you know obviously
there's obviously they do fund the you
know the lawyers on the other um people
that are accessing or you know working
in the program s however um there's a
surplus of funds as well that are
supposed to
be again going to the families okay all
right I just want to get clar so
basically what she's saying if I
understand it correctly is the towns are
giving these public funds to lobbyists
which are say these um um benefits are
available to people but then when you go
to get the benefit it's they're not
actually there right thank you great I
can give you some examples of the
programs but if you could provide those
U Offline that would be great okay um
thank you very much for your testimony
you're welcome um chair would
call uh chair would call and I'm hoping
I'm reading it correctly Allison
nolles how' I do
no you knew who I meant though right
okay what um how how do could you please
introduce yourself my name is Alison NAB
I'm from Rockingham 12 uh which is
stratum over in the Sea Coast I'm also
the vice chair of the stratum select
board and I've been on the town
Conservation Commission for about 15
years um you have received a letter from
our town in opposition to this bill but
I just wanted to come speak against it
as well um the budgets in our town as in
most towns are set by Town staff and the
select board the budget advisory
committee and are authorized at Town
meeting um these funds can be used to
keep us informed and participate in the
legislative process as any industry
impacted by legislative legislation set
by the state house this legislation
affects many things for a town including
things from meeting minutes to zoning
ordinances and it is impossible for me
to imagine that our town select board
planning board Conservation Commission
Town staff would be able to follow
legislation on their own and to advocate
for it to come here and Advocate it for
it um I think this letter we wrote you
is probably one we've written maybe like
we've written three in five years so
having um an organization that helps
keep us informed on legislation and to
advocate for us it's extremely important
and lastly I'll just say that I think a
bill that um that includes penalties and
charges against Volunteers in towns will
have a chilling effect on the volunteers
that keep our towns running so that is
another matter of concern about this
legislation and I thank you for your
time I'm happy to take any questions
thank you uh representative
costable thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking the question um can you
who is who is the US that um is being
advocated for um and does that include
your uh the town people as well yes yes
I mean obviously like in every town our
town select board planning board
committees are trying to make the best
decisions possible for the town and um
keeping us informed on legislation
that's going to impact us it's
incredibly important the town's people
it's part of the reason I ran for the
State House I felt like the long arm of
conquered kept knocking on our door with
new regulations and decisions that
impacted our boards our committees and
our
residents thank
you
um representative mcarter sorry thank
you Mr chair uh thank you for taking my
question uh we're you're very involved
in your your town governance obviously
uh does your Town segregate funds
specifically uh per uh chapter
15 um remind me what chapter 15 are you
asking if we segregate the funds from
the state yes it's it's a part of the
bill right now but it segregate them yes
no it also it already exists 155 asked
you to ex um segregate St IM we do
although i''d have to check with our
finance administrator but I I'm sure we
are compliant on that okay thank you
thank you for the question
F the
questions seeing none thank you thank
you for your I'm sorry for not calling
you earlier your your card didn't
indicate that you are a representative
yeah chair would call in Marie
bfield asking for three minutes and does
support the
bill welcome to legislative
Administration oh good morning um I
normally am in the education committee
so it's nice to be here um my name is
Amry Banfield for the record I am a
parental rights advocate in New
Hampshire focused on education so I'm
going to probably speak more to your
school boards Association School
administrators
Association the practice of using tax
dollars out of the school budget for
lobbying takes money away from public
education so we need to be very clear
about that I would imagine that most
taxpayers have no idea that their money
is going to pay lobbyists who often
times Lobby against what they support
this is a big scam on taxpayers teachers
must pay their representation why is it
okay for money to be taken out of the
budget to fund lobbyist for the school
boards and
administrators I've been advocating and
lobbying on behalf of parents throughout
New Hampshire for about 15 years
oftentimes these two organizations will
offer opposing testimony they are parted
out of the school budget
I've never received a dime everything
I've done has been on a volunteer basis
this kind of lobbying by the nhba and
the nhsaa is not representative of all
taxpayers who fund these two
organizations schools are not funding
lobbyists for teachers or parents out of
the
budget the nhsa and nhsaa take political
positions that their funders do not
support that is why we have a problem
with this because I know that that
question came up
earlier
um if this is going to be acceptable
then this budget should be open up to
everybody they need to be paying every
parent that comes and testifies why is
it that we're discriminated against when
it comes to funding lobbyists how about
paying the the parents who come for
special ed how about funding parents who
just come and speak
why is it just some get to lobby for
their political positions but nobody
else
can I consider that Viewpoint
discrimination I follow legislation I'm
not and I'm on my own and I follow a lot
of legislation so I'm not sure why
that's so difficult for these towns um I
could use a secretary but I don't have
money for that
um these organizations uh I think you
brought up earlier do other things and
that again is not part of this bill so
if they want to I know the nhba proposes
model legislation for
schools um but that model legislation is
being charged at this or being
challenged at the Supreme Court right
now so it's costing a school money to
fight a parent who's suing the
Manchester schools
over uh model policy that they suggested
to the school which they did withdraw
they did withdraw their support the
nhba but all policies at the school
should be based on federal state laws
and rules shouldn't have you shouldn't
be able to pull out model legislation
because they're supposed to be based on
state
laws um so I don't even think we're
getting our money's worth when it comes
to what they're doing in terms of
offering model legislation
but again this applies to lobbying and I
think that if we're going to have
lobbying then you know and you and if
you know if you don't accept this then
how about a bill that opens up paying
all of us thank
you thank you um
questions I have one sure um in your
travels in 15 years um have you run into
instances where
school boards or School administrators
weren't aware of laws that passed that
maybe weren't
um enjoyed by the um the school
administrators or the school um boards
Association have you have you heard of
of information not being passed if it
was not um um favorable to the to the
school administrators or to the board um
so basically what you're saying is that
the if the law passed it's supposed to
be put in policy correct and if it
didn't if it didn't get put in policy
have I seen that no I have not seen that
but I have seen the opposite with the
jbat policy where the policy if you
looked at the bottom you it always cites
laws and if you actually read the laws
that it's cited for instance in the jbab
policy uh under the Privacy section it
says for school Personnel to hide
information from parents about their
children this is why it's in it's being
challenged at the Supreme Court there's
no law that says that schools should be
hiding information from parents so that
model policy was not based on any
specific law that says you know hide or
light a parents about information about
their children so the opposite I've said
I I've seen that makes sense
representative
sers thank you Mr chair have you seen
through the years uh where in you
focusing on schools districts one
District giving uh many districts give
to um the SBA for
example and the SBA would Lobby for one
position over another position so
basically one District wants this the
other District wants that but the SBA
has to take position on one of the other
um no I haven't seen where that that is
split in terms of because if somebody
would come in from a school district and
come before the legisl or before a
committee they would probably be
speaking on their own behalf I do know
that obviously they take a position um I
think the anti-bullying position several
years ago uh I supported it uh because
it would hold schools accountable for
negligent gross negligence if they were
ignoring bullying and then um the the
school board's Administration or the
school administr this has been several
years ago so I'm trying to do this by
memory I think opposed it at that time
but I can tell you that the parents of
kids who were
bullied uh you know we had Parents
testifying were were supportive because
one girl was thrown down the stairs at
at the Manchester school and when they
when they sued they got they got nothing
because there was nothing in the bill so
there is a major conflict often times on
based on what they're presenting with
what the people who pay their
bills believe or
support Al um others no thank you very
much for your
testimony
chair will
call trying to alternate here if it's
not uh clear it's kind of difficult to
do um chair will call uh Kimberly
halquist how do I do perfect well
done welcome to legislative
Administration you represent the town of
lond uh New London New London yes thanks
very much Mr chairman and members of the
committee um good morning um I am here
representing the selectman of the town
of New London who asked that you oppose
this bill New London has been a member
of the nhma for decades uh and has
always felt that the taxpayer fund spent
on membership um has dues has resulted
in many times that amount in savings um
as direct result of the advocacy of
nhma most towns and cities could not
afford to devote staff time to
researching bills and then sending staff
here to conquer on a regular basis to
express their municipalities support for
or opposition to bills that would impact
their communities most towns have all
they can do to keep up with responding
with the many citizens who come to our
office the city hall or town hall call
or email we simply can't provide you
with the information that you need to be
effective legislators without the
assistance of
nhma with the pulled resources of the
towns and cities of New Hampshire
municipalities and their citizens can
have a voice in conquered for a very
Moder
amount of money this model saves
taxpayer dollars and we urge you to
oppose this bill to support elected
Municipal officials and their taxpayers
thank you I'm happy to answer any
questions that you might have thank you
for your testimony um are there
questions uh rep
mcarter thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question does you're you're
from New London yep does the town of New
London segregate funds per RSA chapter
not that I'm aware ofan you mean the
question on the state funds that come in
rooms and meals tax uh Transportation
funds yes not that I'm aware of okay
thank you
yep representative Pearson thank you Mr
chair and and thank you for coming up
here uh New London right is said okay as
a member you're a member of the New
Hampshire Municipal Association is there
it is there any sort of rules or
prohibition or requirements as a member
that prohibits
you as a town to come up
here and fight against a position of the
organization to which you belong to no
okay I would feel the selectman in New
London would feel free to come and speak
if they were opposed to something that
nhma was advocating that what you mean y
that's exactly what I mean thank
you uh I'll follow up on that um would
it be do you understand or um is it your
reading of the the existing of the bill
as it stands
now that it would prohibit you from
testifying in the future I think that
that's a good question Mr chairman I
kind of wondered about that because I am
paid by the town so I'm government money
is paying me to be here at this moment
so I'm not a registered lobbyist so
perhaps I could still come here but I do
I was I was wondering that myself
yes I one last question um have you ever
run into time when um you have as a
select board um requested input or um
had a discussion with the Reps or
Senators that live in your District um
on legislation absolutely um
representative eel and um wolf yes I'm
in contact with them as well we are too
yeah um thanks very much uh no further
questions thank you for coming thank
you chair would call
um yeah um I'm gonna murder this one too
um
Mora what is it Mora Ryan Ryan Mora
Ryan would be me thank you I apologize
for your problem my name is not English
so uh my parents have a good sense of
humor
um my name is Mora Ryan I'm a member of
the public um and I'm here to talk
about support for this bill I personally
don't know representative yala
representative sodi is one of my
representatives from my area um but I
wanted to say that I don't want my
taxpayer dollars going to fund groups
like nhba which
often express opinions that are contrary
to my own and to my son's education I
have a son who has
autism this is a little loud they never
make these for short people
um my son and I have been involved in a
brutal battle which has emotionally left
me completely bere because my son
deserves an education the state promises
him an education they say he's entitled
to an adequate education and I had to go
20 rounds with my school district to try
and get him what the federal and state
law have promised
me I have come up here to testify on
bills one of my bills which I wanted
sponsored was SB 381 which went before
the finance committee a committee which
I am not allowed to testify in front of
and my that the lobbyist nhba was right
there front and center and not only were
they allowed to testify before the
finance committee a committee to which I
was able to give zero input two two
lobbyists from the audience agreed to
write an amendment for that committee on
that bill and they wrote a bunch of
stuff for themselves in that bill so I
don't appreciate that and I'm making
that clear right now um I have seen
lobbying organizations put loopholes to
make it so that schools don't have to
follow the law I've seen them make it
interpretations of the law that are not
accurate I've been to some of the
trainings and I've seen their
interpretations of the law and
personally if I were represented to
represent if I were elected to represent
the people I would want to know what the
people think not what some organization
thinks you can still go to their website
you can still read their opinions they
do take positions on bills I track bills
I do it through the you guys upgraded
the system you can now just check off a
box and you get an email it's very easy
um I want to tell you at present 4% of
students on IEPs will have any
opportunity for post-secondary Education
yet the greater majority of them receive
regular High School diplomas why is that
I sit on the state advisory committee
for special education and we have a
lobbyist on that
committee I also believe that these
lobbying these firms like nhma were
formed by members and they were for
towns to discuss issues within the Town
members they're no longer represented by
me members are the towns and the people
are members of them but they're run by
attorneys and the thing that attorneys
like to do best is create more work for
attorneys in my town we have attorneys
redacting right to no requests we don't
need attorneys to redact right to no
requests the attorneys are probably
laughing is they're paying aemp $7 an
hour to black out a name so I am here to
support this bill I am going to follow
up with written testimony because I'm
running out of time but I also want to
tell you that I had done some research
on whether or not current laws were more
in align with lobbying groups or the
actual constituents and current research
shows that laws are more in alignment
with lobbyist which represent a minor
port of the population and not
constituents I am happy to take any
questions and 100% I support this
bill I appreciate your testimony uh
representative payer yeah thank you I'm
sorry I missed what town you are from
I'm from Linder londondary okay yes and
um have you participated what yes
followup sorry thank you thank you um
have you voiced your concerns in your
within your town during the budgeting
process yes I have
okay absolutely okay and how did that go
that did um they actually did not really
acknowledge that the school board said
even if I got the votes to override it
that they would do it anyway and do you
know the amount of sorry I'm sorry I'm
new on the procedurals may I ask another
followup y yes one more oh okay one more
thank you um do you know the dollar
amount that your town pays
for the this these items that you're
concerned about it's actually very
difficult to track because not only is
it nhba it's business administrators
superintendent organization special
education organization I know nhma got
almost $1.5 million from Town's last
year in du's loan from your town uh from
the state as a
whole okay thank
you further questions representative
Hobson thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony um you obviously uh
know this well I'm having trouble
keeping up with you can you repeat the
statistic you mentioned about the IEP
students and the number that graduate 4%
will have any opportunity to go into
postsecondary education including the
babysitter Pro babysitting program at
Community College I think you said you
were submitting testimony I will send in
a written testimony because I was
running out of time but yes I can I can
do that great thank you um any
further seeing none thank you very much
thank you just a quick bookkeeping note
um if members feel the need we're past
noon time if um individual members not
all at once and leave me here but if
people want to slip down and grab
something in the cafeteria that would be
great um I will stay here um we do
have nine nine or 10 additional pink
cards so um but not not all of you jump
up and run thank thank you um chair
would call representative
aers who supports the
bill welcome to legislative
Administration thank you and it's
actually
ORS I occasionally have both ORS in the
water but I mostly operate on one I was
I was
misinformed that's quite all right so I
would just like to uh see if I can add
to the testimony we've already heard
uh listening to representative yella and
others I would like to raise a couple
points uh a couple issues one it sounds
to me as though an inquire is required
and needed as a minimum as to how funds
are being handled and accounted for by
towns and
municipalities uh representative tyy uh
it sounds like this legislation could
help or hurt his cause and it's obvious
that uh from what I've heard in
representative Tierney's testimony and
others that this is a
beneficial uh service for him however it
sounds like the money is not being
properly separated into different colors
of money and by that I mean as a former
government auditor money is put in
different buckets for different uses and
it may be blue red white whatever yellow
color the money is but if the money
starts to get mixed into a different
bucket and now we can't tell what color
it is uh that is totally inappropriate
and I was in a situation where a
president vice president of company
mixed that money and lost their job so
uh as a
former auditor I would say that this
definitely needs to be looked into in
addition it sounds like what's happening
over at the LSR Arena also needs to be
looked into as far as I'm I understood
matter of fact I read it this morning I
believe in an email that was put out
that this is supposed to be private only
those that are sponsors co-sponsors Etc
should have this information and if this
information is leaking out to lobus
somebody's hand needs
slapping and with that I think I'm
finished I'll take one
question who gets it you do you're the
chair
uh your town um Chai Chester Chai
Chester um are you aware whether your
town
um a segregates the funds as they're
currently required in law from State
sources and B does your Town um get in
touch with you about issues that um are
affecting the town that are asking you
to um represent them when they come to
when you come to conquer so because I
like you and I do know that was two
questions
so so with that yes I was actually at
the pre-budget meeting for our town last
night and they do separate these kind of
monies out to the best of my knowledge
from what I remember seeing and looking
over the budget and number two uh they
don't need to reach out to me so I'm I'm
reaching out to them but it would be
nice if there was something going on
that somebody would tip me off but there
is conversation there is um a a pipeline
for your town um to get their feelings
known here in conquered through you or
Andor your
Senator I would hope so I really don't
have let me re let me re let me start
again with that answer so one of the
constituents in my town asked me to show
up at a school board meeting and that
same constituent was there in the
meeting last night and thank me for
coming so I would I would hope there was
a reason why they're asking me to show
up at these
meetings thank you you're welcome thank
you representative ORS have a nice
day um chair would call um Mary Smith um
who supports the bill and is looking for
two
minutes I'll be brief uh I am Mary Smith
of Manchester New
Hampshire uh and I am not a
lobbyist I'm just a person I took time
out of my day to come here to testify on
this bill and to others and uh that's
time I could have been spending on the
job site right now uh painting a home so
that someone can go live in it in
Manchester but instead I'm here and I've
done this on multiple occasions
not getting paid to do it but what
really grinds my gears is when I am up
here and I take this time out of my day
that I could be a productive member of
society paying taxes and instead I'm
here and my testimony is seceded by and
preceded by individuals from these
organizations like uh nhma but not just
nhma uh for which they hold entirely
contrary uh opinions on the legislation
that they get to express at my cost and
that's just ridiculous that's like
absurd and I'm I really appreciate that
there were people here who are getting
paid right now at this testimony to
testify against this bill who you know I
don't want to be paying for them to be
advocating against what I want as a
taxpayer if they want to come here in
some unofficial capacity where I'm not
footing the bill that would be great but
unfortunately that's not the case and so
um that's the first major point I I'd
like to express in this testimony and
the other is I wonder how many towns
that sent in letters to this committee
um also mentioned in those letters that
they clearly segregate These funds uh as
what is uh currently law
155 um so if you have any questions uh
for me uh I'm happy to take them uh
because this is not hypothetical it's
not hypothetical that like oh
hypothetically there are people whose
interests are being counter represented
with their money here it's actually
happened to me as someone who is not a
lobbyist here uh in
conquer thank you um are there
questions I have one um have you ever
tried at the local level um to not
have the the funds um
paid by to lobbying organizations that
um have you ever tried to have that
removed from the
budget no I have not gone to the um and
the
uh the matter is different for cities
and towns I think uh and I don't know I
could bring this up in the next um uh
local meeting in Manchester about if
they uh do this and if they don't if
they'd be willing not to but my
understanding is that nhma doesn't uh
give their members the opportunity to
not do this that nhma doesn't ask
members okay would you like us to not
allocate any funds to lobbying and if
they did oh well that would be great and
then I would Advocate that um the uh
Alderman that represent me and the mayor
choose not to but to my understanding
nhma and perhaps these other
organizations do not give their members
the opportunity to earmark those funds
in that way and say oh no we don't want
any money to be spent towards lobbying
does that answer your question it
certainly did uh representative sellers
has a followup I believe yeah thank you
Mr chair have you been to a budget
meeting and uh where they actually
present the budget like a budget hearing
in the
past I've I've reviewed the documents uh
online but I have not physically myself
been in the meetings for
Manchester
uh further questions seeing none thank
you very much for your
testimony um
chair will call trying again to get the
opposition up hold a
second we have request for a five minute
recess um be back at uh 25
pass
thanks
okay we're
back um chair would call David it's
either Karan or Karen or
sorry please introduce yourself welcome
to legislative
Administration back in Canada with my
grandparents to be cut home but I but I
call it Dave Karen I am the Town
Administrator in Derry and thank you for
inviting me to speak and thank you for
your time uh I think we all can agree
that this process here throughout the
legislature is about a sharing of ideas
and information and I think it behooves
and benefits all of us the legislature
towns and cities and our citizens who we
serve to make sure that we do that in
the most efficient way possible so to
provide some additional information is
that every Community state is a member
of NH Ma and every other year we go
through a process called the legislative
policy process which essentially groups
three different committees dealing with
Finance General Administration and land
use and environmental to look at policy
positions to present to all of our
members the combined participants in
that process represents 75 communities
fully one-third of all of our of all of
our folks they go through a process
whereby they have meeting meetings and
then we have what I call is NH May's
town meeting where every town and city
in the state has a seat at the table to
review these policies and they vote on
them they also adopt what they call
guiding principles essentially there's
any
legislation which doesn't fit to one of
those categories they discussed our
professionals at
nhma comes back and Compares that
legislation against the principles if
they're still unclear then the
professionals will come back to the
board of directors and we meet monthly
to review the legislation and request
direction from us so you can see it's a
really Bottoms Up approach and I hope
you agree with me it's very transparent
and also it's very efficient now
removing nhma from the process will just
reduce the the efficiencies of the
process instead of having a coordinated
process in which all communities
particip ipated at the outset you're
going to have a lot more people here
testifying like I am today in which I'm
not back in my hometown doing equally
important
work second on the question about fiscal
notes I don't know what the process is
but I would think for efficiency it
would make a lot more sense to get nh's
input into those which has a subject
matter expertise and has the input input
of all the organizations as opposed to
going out and trying to get information
from 234 cities and towns because I
think at the end of the day we're all
looking for good government and I think
I I'm not quite sure what the impetus
for this bill is but I know the end
result is is going to be less
communication there's going to be more
information falling through the crack
craps and the not so good go not the
good public policy we're trying to
create through this process will be not
as good as it was before so I stand
proposi this bill be glad to answer any
questions thank you for your testimony
are there question representative Hobson
thank you for taking my question um I
was wondering what position do you serve
on here just as dairy mun I'm sorry I'm
the town ministrator and I uh I serve
the pleasure of the seven member elected
Town Council follow up follow up and may
I ask uh is that a full-time position in
G yes I'm appointed okay thank you
fulltime plus
one representative sers thank you Mr
chair you mentioned a few minutes ago
that there'll be less Communications but
I'm seeing yourself here and I saw
another uh select board member here it
seems like more towns are coming out
yeah more people are going to have to I
I agree more people are going to have to
come but that seems to me it's more
Communications would you agree or
disagree on that I'm not following your
reasoning yeah thank thanks for the
question I I suspect if there was one
Municipal issue or maybe even a half
dozen during a session it wouldn't it
wouldn't impact our operations where you
have as you know dozens upon dozens of
legislation which impact municipalities
and its taxpayers uh then it makes sense
to us to develop this Central Clearing
House of information and supported by
the professionals and
H yes Mr chair thank you you do realiz
this bill is not saying they can't do
lobbying they just have to have that
money to pay the lobbyist from another
fund
right I I I do see that and I just
question where those funds would come
from in a realistic manner which just
won't
happen um further questions I have one
reck Mard go thank you Mr Mr chair thank
you for taking my question so are you
suggesting that the um recent discovery
and I noticed it too as recently as last
week that two of my bills um the fiscal
notes were either previewed or created
by the New Hampshire Municipal
Association are you suggesting that um
our practice of doing that through our
um office of legislative Services isn't
appropriate
relationship uh when we as the
representatives are supposed to be
presenting legislation that is for the
benefit of our
constituents is it your is it your do do
you submit that this is an
appropriate uh relationship for them to
have preview legislation yeah let me not
comment on relationship because I don't
know much about the process my point is
very simple is that before a committee
or the legislature consider is any
legislation you should have the benefit
of the best available information I
think we can all agree to that so
whether nhma representing every
community in this state provides your
information at the beginning of the
process or at step two or step three I
don't know about that but the
legislature should have the benefit of
that information at some point during
the
process further questions I have one
um we have some testimony that we
received in um by um writing that
questions um duplicity whether there are
um um dues being paid to and we seem to
be circling in on nhma but I think part
of that is from the people that are
testifying
um if if all the cities and towns are
members of
nhma are there other within your your
town are there other um groups of people
that are also members of nhma that that
U those dues are paid for out of the
taxpayer funds as well and and and this
was pointed out out of the County as
well that that they too may be also a
member of nhma so in in the letter that
we received there were three separate
organizations that all were paying dues
to the same organization is that is that
possible in your
estimation thanks for the question I'm
I'm sorry I'm confused I didn't follow
it along let me let me see if I can ton
ofer pays dues at nhma we have like the
Chief of Police Association in which the
chief has a line adance budget for that
Association and so they all have groups
that Advocate not Advocates a bad word
to support them in their training in
their conferences I don't know how much
advocacy they actually do but I are they
also I might apologize for the uh for
the confusion um are is the county that
you belong to also a member of nhma and
are are any of the cities in uh any of
the Town Offices also members of nhma
are there is it possible you could be
paying multiple memberships to nhma well
uh I don't believe Rockingham County is
a member of nhma
and we don't pay dues to the County's
Association okay thank you
representative
Tierney not a question but an answer to
what you just asked from nh's Municipal
director I'll there okay
thank representa sers thank you Mr chair
um so to follow up on the chair's
question do any of the Departments
please fire Highway Department uh conser
conservation committee along with the
town do they all or may all pay into
nhma for example no town of dery gets
one bill and it's and it's uh they their
responsib responsive to all of our
departments further questions seeing
none thank you very much thank you for
your time appreciate
it chair would call
Matthew
St
representing
y welcome to legislative
Administration all
right all right uh ladies and gentlemen
of the New Hampshire House Legislative
Administration committee thank you for
taking the time to could you introduce
yourself please yes uh my name is
Matthew sa I live in Manchester uh this
my first time uh giving testimony before
this committee and before the state
house um uh just to roll back a little
bit ladies Gentlemen of the committee
thank you for taking the time to hear my
testimony um thank you to each and every
concerned taxpayer that has showed up in
support of this bill today I haven't
said that I'll begin taxpayer funded
lobbying is where public officials use
public to advocate for Public Policy uh
thank thankfully representative yella
has introduced a bill to address this
issue uh that's the kind of legisl
legislative change that I support
wholeheartedly uh taxpayer funded
lobbying is an egregious misuse of
taxpayer dollars that is undemocratic
goes against free speech of the taxpayer
and is one of the reasons that we have
uh continual corruption in government
how is this a violation of taxpayers
free speech uh given that the interests
of citizens May differ from the their
governments citizens legislative Lobby
efforts towards State elected officials
might be adversely affected by the
distinct the disadvantage they face when
contending with the agenda of taxpayer
funded lobbyists hired by these
political subdivisions additionally
those taxpayer funded lobbying efforts
often take positions contrary to
taxpayers policy preferences as an
example homeowners may prefer prefer
lower property taxes while a tax jur
jurisdiction may be employing lobbyists
through an association to protect or
even raise these taxes these property
taxes um here are some issues that uh
tax payer funded lobbyist groups like
The New Hampshire Municipal Association
I'm going to have to pick on them again
uh support that the average taxpayer
might find contrary to their belief
system of the issues that the publicly
funded nhma addresses that actually
relate to municipalities here are some
that your average taxpayer may not agree
with uh the nhma supports the authority
of M municipalities to regulate or limit
the use of firearms on Municipal
property to regulate the carrying of
firearm Firearms by Municipal Employees
while on duty the nhma also support the
ability to recover reasonable labor
costs and other costs for responding to
voluminous or excessive record requests
um the nhma also supports greater
flexibility in the processing of
absentee ballots all pulled directly
from the nhma NH HMA
website um all issues that are paid are
sted stances paid for by your average
taxpayer through local funds to their
local boards to the nhma to Lobby
us do legislative ADV advocacy groups
like The N nhma that receive funds from
towns and cities City cities exclusively
Lobby using those funds for issues
related to these towns and cities no um
and I'm happy to provide a few examples
again pulled directly from the website
uh the nhma supports legislation
amending Motor Vehicle Registration
enforcement laws to ensure the
collection of all state and local
registration fees owed by New Hampshire
residents then H also supports
legislation that protects and preserves
local natural resources and public
infrastructure bill
Community
resilience and fosters adaptation to
climate change and mitigates its risks
then H also supports legislation and
policies that encourage creative and
flexible approaches to meeting housing
needs of current and future demographics
in different
regions again all pulled from nh's
website I'll say it again this is a
corrupt practice that allows for
egregious spending misuse of taxpayer
dollars violation of taxpayers free
speech rights and a potential inhibition
for the average citizen's advocacy
efforts to prosper of this bill is not
meant to limit a selectman or a public
official from engaging in the public
Prof process from engaging in the public
process it's meant to prohibit them from
paying lobbyists to do their job for
them for all these reasons and more I
support House Bill 1479 in its entirety
and would encourage you all to do the
same thank you for allowing me this time
thanks written testimony do you have
that you can submit to the clerk yes sir
absolutely I don't have it with me right
now but I can certainly submit it that'd
be great thank you uh further questions
representative sers thank you Mr chair
so you believe are you you believe at
this point that the um nonprofits are
these Outside Agency that the talents
would give money to don't necessarily
always represent the people
absolutely um
so the issue here is is that it's a free
speech violation where um these towns
and these municipalities obviously you
can win a 51 to 49 race um and these
these committee members and these
Selectmen um can use the taxpayer
dollars of people that might not
completely agree with the positions that
they're pushing
um so that that's it's it's it's it's a
way for public officials to have use
taxpayer dollars to compel the speech of
their taxpayers um where they might not
always agree with the issues that
they're
pushing thank you um no further
questions thank you very much for your
testimony the chair would call Bonnie
ham um I believe from the town of
Woodstock
who opposes the Bill thank you I
didn't I was speak but just listening I
just please first introduce yourself for
the for the YouTubers that want to know
who you are okay I am Bonnie ham I am a
resident of the townwood stock I have
been a member I am not currently serving
but I 18 uh years in the legislature and
I have been a
municipal um official for 50 two years
I've served on all the boards um
throughout the town throughout the
school
district my opinion and this is my
personal opinion is that New Hampshire
Municipal Association serves the same
exact
people that the members of the
legislature serve everybody all the
towns in towns and cities in the state
of New Hampshire equals the same exact
people that the legislature represents
the same exact people so I find New
Hampshire Municipal Association speaking
on behalf of the towns and cities
valuable valuable valuable information
and valuable valuable input as to what
the cities in towns think what they need
to do their job which is a different
level of government but it is government
also and they're trying to meet the
needs of the same exact people we are
trying to meet down here in the
legislature you know I hear the
individual rights when you get involved
in personal Liberties and individual
rights it gets a little difficult
because the municipal
Association um is looking at the global
picture everybody what is good for the
environment what what is good to run the
town under to provide a quality of life
I find them very trustworthy I find them
a very very very valuable resource of
information now maybe there's a way to
them not being perceived as having as
much impact such as perhaps weighing in
the fiscal impacts of bills maybe that
needs to be changed if there's an
exception there and they're the only
ones that are weighing in to that degree
maybe that shouldn't happen I don't know
but I think there's got to be a way to
salvage this and here from the New
Hampshire Municipal Association in a
meaningful way because they're well
intended they're speaking for us as a
state and as a
town and that's just my personal View
and I feel strongly about it I feel very
strongly about it and I have 52 years
experience observing and using and
participating in um their processes and
their
organization great thank you very much
for your testimony uh would you take
questions if there are any yes
absolutely are there any
questions representative sers sorry I
gota ask uh thank you honorable and um
thank you for serving the legisl 52
years three um in those all those years
have you ever seen maybe a decision from
and we're again we're still picking on
nhma but on on any of them like so the
town of woodstar would want a bill that
would go this way or advocate for a bill
that would go this way but the city of
Manchester wants to go this way have you
ever seen
that well that could happen obviously ly
because um there are Regional
differences um there's
different um economies different um
where I live uh we're in the northern
part of the state we might be more
interested in in preserving the
environment and making sure we've got
roads to get there uh so the tourists
can come see us and Manchester or
conquer Nashville might have a
have a different
perspective um but I've been very very
very involved on the regional Planning
Commission level also and I have found
in general what is good for one is good
for all there's a lot of things you got
to look at from a Woodstock point of
view um and if you're a Woodstock
official that even isn't your first
priority
um but you got to consider it um I had a
friend that always would say a rising a
rising Tide Rises All Ships so what is
good for Manchester is good for
Woodstock what it's one state it's a
small state
so um a town like Woodstock can kind of
go along with something that seems like
it might benefit Manchester more than
Woodstock and by Versa if it's good for
the state it's good for jobs it's good
for the economy it's good for providing
a place that people want to live that
people want to visit what's good for one
is good for
all I think you might have disagreement
with a place like Dalton they they may
think that Manchester doesn't speak for
them but um thank you very much
representative
payer hi thank you for being here um
would do you since you've been in local
government for so long would does your
town do town meeting format
yes keep going okay um and if your
residents didn't want your town to spend
money on a nhma or whatever within their
budget would they be able to vote
collectively majority rule to take out
those dollars Absol absolutely um my
particular Town got mad at at an
organization not Municipal Association
but another one and we stopped paying
dues for a while because we weren't
happy with them but we went back after a
while and we went back so it's it's
absolutely optional on the town level
the ultimately the voters decide the
voters are would St decide where they
want to spend their
money and and um this isn't answering
specifically that question but I I also
have served on let's try to answer their
question that would be good all right
thank you but yes the vo is
um can decide not to join our
representative costable thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question are you telling me that at Town
meetings that um the people can pull out
just the lobbying effort would not not
the do to nhma or any other Association
but specifically what we're talking
about here is lobbying efforts I'm not
aware that lobbying is a separate line
item that we that the people can take
out I don't think they could amend and
and they could amend um the warrant
article to send Municipal Association
less money I mean they could they could
they could take out that line at them
it's it's in the budget by the time you
get to town meeting it's in the budget
and it's Pro probably under the uh
selectman's budget most likely and um
somebody from the floor can say well I
only want to send um New Hampshire
Municipal Association half as much and I
want to send a message that I enjoy
their um legal services and their other
programs they have but boy I I don't
want to pay for their lobbying somebody
on the floor could could make that
motion and say I'm going to cut it in
half so they don't have any lobbying
money and you selectman you better tell
them
so representative MC yeah MC Carter
thank you thank you Mr chair low blood
sugar
I so are you suggesting that um a member
of the public a resident in Woodstock
for example could uh by warrant article
petition town to cut their membership
dues in half uh or or some arbitrary
figure because it was my understanding
that the fees paid uh by the
municipalities to the New Hampshire
Municipal Association are strictly uh
derived from population so can you
clarify that for me please um it's in
it's in the budget I mean we do have a
pink card from the municipal Association
may be a good question it's it's
pro-rated based on population Manchester
pays more than
Woodstock um but yes a citizen can put
in a petition with 15 signatures if
that's the ratio needed and I think it
is in Woodstock I want you to include
this warrant article and the warrant
article can say anything that's gerain
of course um
to uh municipal government they can't
bring up topics that have nothing to do
with running a town or a budget but yes
it can unlikely you know it doesn't
happen a lot but it can thank you thank
you for your testimony thank you chair
would call Nancy
Beerman supports the
bill yes I do hi Nancy Beerman how you
doing welcome to legislative
Administration thank you I'm usually
over at education or Health and Human
Services um so uh former teacher here 15
years um and I would like to remind
people that we have a um the type of
government that we have is a
representative government we have a
constitutional republic so the people
vote for their representatives which are
all of you sitting here and we expect
that you would represent our opinions
and our concerns when we contact
you as far as I know and as long as I've
taught us history um lobbyists were not
part of the Constitution
and I have sat in many meetings and
hearings over the last two years and
it's pretty sad when I'm sitting there
and I've taken time out of my day and um
I'm the only one there and then there's
10 other lobbyist that are there and
then I look and I say oh my goodness my
tax money is paying for them and they're
opposing it um recently I was over the
education department testifying against
obscene books that we are finding in
School libraries and my tax money is
being used by these lobbyists to say no
we're going to keep them in the
schools
um this morning on my way here I was
listening to Drew Klein who is the chair
of the New Hampshire School Board
Association he has a nice little morning
talk show um he said that New Hampshire
has had per cost per pupil has gone up
immensely and when he's done research
that cost has gone to administrators it
is not going to the pupils
themselves finally we have um a friend
who has been watching this at home and
she just now got an email trying to
figure out the dues and the fees and
going to the New Hampshire school
administration
Association and um it's immense I mean
between the superintendent the assistant
superintendent the total is over
$14,000 and again it's very hard to
figure out exactly which is actually
going to the New Hampshire school um
administrators Association because again
it's not spelled out section by section
in the school board but she was able um
the person from the budget committee was
able to give her some broad categories
and it's $144,000 so we're not talking a
hundred or $200 in the school um budgets
and um it's a lot of money um the town
next to me they just passed um their
budget for the deliberative session and
their taxes if it gets voted on by the
people are going to go up over
$1,200 this year they can't afford it
even though there was people there
saying look I can't pay my taxes I have
to choose between taxes and
food and they're still spending more
money than than the residents have and
the lobbyist I think a lot of that is
behind that so thank you questions
concerns problems sorry that's how I
ended every lesson as a teacher it's the
teacher in you um representative sellers
thank you Mr chair thank thank you for
my question so I think we heard from the
administrator or uh London Dairy or
dairy I figet which town but any in any
case um so the taxpayers pay the
property tax to the town the town gives
money to let's you know to a nhma for an
example but we also de money to each of
the Departments so they can spend money
as well and I think we heard from the
the uh the uh administrator saying that
like the police department will have a a
police department Association they give
the library has the Ala they give to
right so in essence we're not just
giving just to one organization we're
giving to a lot do you know like how
many and about how much a town would
actually give or maybe a town that would
be a great research
proposition I mean it it's it's
everywhere and um we have to decide as a
government and you have to decide as
Representatives when we come and speak
whose voice holds more weight and I
would hope that a concerned citizen
coming here and speaking to you would
hold more weight than somebody that is
paid and I am not paid in fact I'm
probably getting a parking ticket right
now as I'm speaking to you because this
one a little longer than I thought so
you try to guess when you come here as
to how much so we'll see how much my
bill is for today so you try to figure
out how long time you take on this end
as well you weren't the only place I
stopped at today so all right um any
further questions so we can get back to
the parking
meter seeing none thank you very much
for your help which lobus wants to pay
my parking
ticket uh the fellow on the end over
here will take care of that for you yeah
yeah
yeah um chair would call William uh M
mney mcky mcken
mckenny
um opposes the bill ask for three
minutes um I'm seeing building officials
yes
sir welcome to legislative
Administration thank you Mr chair
members of the committee I'm Bill mcken
I'm the president of New Hampshire
building officials Association we are a
professional association that represents
over 200 uh code offici officials
licensed design professionals and even
contractors in our membership our Focus
from the New Hampshire building
officials is education education on
codes and educating often legislators on
what the needs are and for the state as
far as
codes the language contained in in House
Bill
1479 um is very similar and has been
introduced and presented in public
hearings during the past two legislative
sessions if I recall correctly each of
those times the recommendations from the
Committees have been
to itl in expedient to
legislate the term lobbyist and this is
one of our major concerns in RSA 151 has
a very broad definition and combined
with the State Attorney General's
opinion it would Encompass many
professional organizations and
associations who aim is to education is
for Education not technically
lobbying many professional associations
such as nhoa receive payments from
communities for their code officials to
be members of our association and to to
attend valuable
training the fees for membership to
those associations are currently within
annual budgets that the voters review
and approve whether it's through town
meeting deliberative session or through
town or city
councils there is a transparent and
public process already to approve these
funds in each Community within our
state nhpa also represents our members
by providing input to to legislators on
bills that may have a positive or even a
negative impact to building and life
safety codes in New Hampshire NH hpoa
and other professional associations are
often requested by legislators to
provide input from our members relative
to legislative specific to our areas of
expertise many smaller communities do
not have the staff or resources to have
their voices heard and conquered those
communities rely on the professional
associations to speak speak on their
behalf on matters of great
importance the many professional
associations do not receive funding
specifically for lobbying nor do they
intend to
Lobby House Bill 1479 while it may be
well- intended to Target specific
lobbying expenditures and to provide
additional transparency could also have
far-reaching negative impacts and
ramifications to many very valuable
professional associations that help to
keep cost from En hamption communities
and with that I will take any questions
thank you for your testimony um are
there questions representative cable
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question although I I believe
you answered it my my question would be
to you uh how much does your Association
spend on lobbying efforts um on either a
yearly or quarterly basis we do not
spend money on lobbying uh efforts are
any of our representation that is here
is by
volunteers follow up thank you Mr chair
um by taking a position on as an
association by taking a position on a
bill that would basically Define
lobbyist I I agree with you that and we
do our best not to take positions the
problem is the the options on our cards
here are support or
oppose there there is no
neutrality uh just to a point of
clarification I have plenty of bills
that have no support no nothing checked
and we usually say neither supporting
nor I will remember that for the future
yep good to know rep
mccotter thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question in your
testimony today uh you indicated that uh
primarily your organization provides
education for your membership is that
accurate yes do they have an option to
select a membership tier that only
provides education and there is no
lobbying uh Services uh
included again we we do not pay for
lobbyist um we did it one time many
years ago and we stopped that effort and
we found it was much better for the
legislators to hear from us the code
officials ourselves rather than paid
lobbyists so there's no option to opt
out of lobbying because we don't have
funding for lobby but if I could
continue by what we doing by just be
being here today someone could say I'm
lobbying and that's not my intent my
intent is to show that This concerns
here that could impact other people then
and I'll put the target back on nhma
because they seem to be the ones you're
looking at there's many more
associations out there there's the
health Officers Association the planners
Association that so and it continues
that you know they all come to you to
proba and guide you one way or the other
on what's best for the State of New
Hampshire thank you rep
no thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I really enjoyed
listening to your testimony and I I wish
there was a way that we could carve out
issues that or pieces that work and
pieces that don't but I myself have been
on the testifying end of bills on the
sponsorship end of bills where
um I I guess I'm up against um a
lobbying organization and I happen to
know that they go directly against um
what taxpayers that put me into office
want so how do we look at this
legislation uh constructively I guess is
is that an interesting or answer able
question in your
mind I really do wish
I I really do wish I had an answer for
that and I know you know two years ago I
worked with a sponsor on a bill that was
similar to this and we attempted to try
and find a way that you know those
associations that are you know trying to
provide
information um and again even by
providing information could you could
you say we're trying to sway your your
Vote or your decision or your your um a
position on a bill I guess yes but I
think it's for you to decide on bills
you should hear both sides of the story
um and hear from all parties um whether
there's pros or cons and then you should
make your
decision
followup thank you uh thank you for
taking my question again if you would um
isn't that what the hearing processes
for to listen to both
sides rather than listen to
lobbyists I I do agree however when you
get into the associations if we if we're
here at the hearings are we being
lobbyists you know and that's I think a
dangerous area to get into and I think
it comes down to that the definition of
what a lobbyist is doesn't carve out
professional associations as an as an
exception it groups them into
that
reper thank you thank you for being here
um I just wanted
to um ask a question is
that this is my first term in the state
house and I appreciate what you do and I
just wanted to say were you aware that
um during our legislative
orientation um rep Stephen Smith advised
us that lobbyists were a good thing and
that we shouldn't um as new represent
resentatives we shouldn't admonish their
presence and and um listen to what they
had to say I just remember that
vividly you are
aware um rep
sers thank you Mr chair and going on rip
hopson's question is do you have any
ideas or any thoughts on how we could
separate uh or um exempt certain
organizations associations or something
like that any I you know to make this so
it's palatable to
others again two two years ago I worked
with the sponsor from this bill to try
and come up with some language that
could do that but it's very difficult
it's difficult to do and I don't know
what the parameters ERS would be to
determine what professional association
is exempt from the lobbying other than
to rewrite the definition of what a
lobbyist
is thank you um the only question I have
is um you seem to be have uh written
down testimony would that be possible to
put into the ab what I what I can do is
I'll clean it up a little bit it's got
some notes and I'll sign it and I can
send it on to the clerk perfect thank
you very much for your help thank you
for coming and seeing us thank you very
much thank
you chair would call
Joan
Dary opposes the bill from New Hampshire
cities and town
clerks ask for two minutes this is going
to be
good hi my name is Joan dargy and the
town clerk in Milford and I'm the
legislative co-chair for the New
Hampshire City and town clerks
Association um I'm here today um to
oppose this bill um for many of the
reasons that have already been said um
the city and town clerks uh each town we
get dues of $20 from from each of our
city and our towns um we Engage The
Services of demur and prol and I'll tell
you in a election year this year that we
have four elections
um looking at a thousand plus lsrs is a
little daunting and thank goodness we
have we engage them to do that for us
they kind of pair it down and then we
are able to focus on those bills that
are that are important to us um one
thing I did want to mention is that as
what Mr mckenny just um spoke to we were
concerned that um If This Were to pass
that as part of the New Hampshire City
and town clerks Association if we came
to Lobby we to testify on a bill that we
would be considered a lobbyist and
therefore would not be able to do that
um I think that everything else has been
said and if anybody has any questions I
welcome any questions thank you very
much for keeping to your two minutes um
representative sers is that
oh oh it's just a automatic move I think
um muscle memory um I do have one
question um
you
um engaged uh Darby and piol Dem sorry
Demmer and part um do
they bring your
feelings um as lobbyists here or are
they just identifying bills that are are
um something that you should be aware of
90% of the time that's what they're
doing um it's when we are not available
to be to test or something that we might
ask them to um speak on behalf of us
thank you uh do you also engage
Representatives directly we do yeah on
occasion yeah okay but it's not always
that easy
to access the
representatives um you know that are
specific to a bill so um we do what we
can I see um last question I have is um
were you aware of of the existing law um
asking for the delineation of State
funds not to be used for so I believe
that um probably most city and towns do
this but they're separated by a general
ledger account so I know that if we
wanted to look at up in Milford how many
what is the total of State funds that
were received we could do that but not I
wouldn't say it would be in a separate
bank account it does require that oh so
I I don't believe there it's not just a
book entry it it does have to be but it
could be and I'll look back I can check
back at finance and check on that as
well great I I believe without speaking
for the for the sponsor I believe that's
part of this is to bring light to light
um the idea that there are existing laws
and and some of those I think by his
letter to the attorney general is
indicating that um he doesn't believe
many are following the existing law so
right I mean it would be easy enough to
separate the funds I mean what we
collect is $20 from each city or town
and nhma out of all the town funds I
mean they it's like a
$1,200 fee plus or minus depending on
the population right yeah thank you very
much for coming I appreciate it you're
welcome thank you no further questions
right
great chair will call Kathy Stacy and I
can read this
card uh Kathy is from the New Hampshire
Association of counties opposes the bill
and has written testimony welcome to
legislative Administration good
afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Kathy Stacy I am
the legislative chair for the New
Hampshire Association of counties and I
am the 30-year register Deeds for
Rockingham
County so the association of counties
has been around for 49 years we
obviously have uh plenty of pieces of
leg legislation that we follow and track
we do have we do uh have a lobbyist that
we do use because currently right now we
are tracking monitoring 700 bills and
100 and 103 in addition to that are top
priority obviously affecting the multi
multitude of departments within the
county as you know you're all members of
the county delegation you vote on our
budget the dues to the New Hampshire
Association of county is are uh included
in that budget uh that you're voting on
annually uh we have always actively
participated in the legislative process
I would say 95% of the time our members
are the ones who come and vote come and
vote I'm sorry come and testify before
the legislature uh and it's not likely
that our uh our lobbyist comes to um
unless it's nobody can actually get here
or it's a the 11th Hour possibly
somebody's putting an onur Bill uh
Amendment onto a bill that we need to
oppose or support what what have you
um we only testify with regards to
legislation that affects County
government whether it's in opposition or
in support um we are always thinking
about what's in the best interest and
you got to re remember that the people
that we send to testify are the ones who
are the experts in the field whether
it's Corrections nursing home registry
of deeds County attorneys I mean we have
a multitude you know uh the nursing home
obviously is the biggest department the
most costly department and you know
sometimes legislation is proposed
that isn't to me totally um thought
through because there's you know
consequences to many bills that they
haven't been thought out and they don't
understand how it will affect the county
um
I'm more concerned as an elected
official who gets paid by County funds
that when I appear before any committee
under this piece of legislation I can be
subjected to a class A
misdemeanor right my finance director or
possibly my Treasurer um can be subject
to a class A misdemeanor because he
signs the checks and it's County funds
that pay me um I don't have you know
obviously I've been told uh that I could
appear here person personally well the
problem with that is if I'm I guess if
I'm taking a vacation day but I still
get paid for vacation time right through
County funds uh you don't meet on
Saturdays or Sundays so I certainly
couldn't come up here and say I'm
meeting I'm coming up here to testify as
a person and not as an elected official
because that's what I am an elected
official and I do Lobby and I do Lobby
locally with my own reps I did two weeks
ago with regards to this piece of
legislation when my executive committee
met to and we discussed this and I gave
them actually the handout that I gave
you and discussed you know um my
thoughts um on this on this piece of
legislation I've also spoken to my nine
I'm from the town of Salem and I've
spoken to my nine State reps with
regards this legislation as well um I
feel it's my obligation to um you know
if I have something that is is NE it's
going to negatively affect especially my
office you will see me up here
testifying be to to give you the
information as to why why it would be
either beneficial or you know in
opposition to our to the best interest
of the Deeds office you know
um again you know we try the association
of counties obviously wants to educate
and promote County government there are
a lot of things that we do a lot of
things that people don't understand that
we do but we play a significant role and
there are a significant amount of bills
that are proposed each year that affect
County government County tax dollars you
know in our constituent so obviously I'm
here in opposition to this bill and I
thank you for your
time thank you um and I want before I
get to the questions I want to uh thank
you for bringing up the idea of whether
you could come and testify um went and
grabb the RSA the books um there are
specific and and it's not affected by
this legislation there are specific
exemptions um or exclusions the
following Communications are excluded
from the regulation imposed by this
chapter of 15 um and and one is public
testimony before any entity subject to
91a public testimony before a
legislative committee or
subcommittee um communication made by a
public official acting in the public
officials um the official's official
capacity so
so I I'm I'm wiping out your concern I
if I if I can may I ask you which
section that is in 15 15 what 151 15 uh
151 Roman
5 um and I read
AB
D thank so all of those are under the
registration of who who must register as
as a lobbyist and all of that
communication is is excl excluded so
very good you're good very good um any
further questions representative
mcarter thank you Mr chair thank you for
your testimony and thank you for taking
my question you're from Rockingham
County cor does Rockingham County
segregate their funds uh per title one
chapter 15.5 okay thank
you further
questions representative sers thank you
Mr
chair um in your position you said you
what register Deeds you said all right
and um so you don't see any conflict of
interest to the
taxpayers to to your job you're doing
because some taxpayers don't want
lobbying some do I understand that but
as I said I mean when I when I come up
here to discuss a piece of legislation
it's going to be something that's going
to be beneficial one way or the other to
the people who utilize my office I've
also been approaching I have also Al
written legislation that's been proposed
and passed here in
conquer pres no representative
payer hi thank you for being here um in
in your experience when you've come in
and and spoken to different groups and
whatnot and then there's been
votes would you say that majority rules
so even if there's a vote and the
majority votes in a certain way then
that even though the the minority may
not be getting what they want that
democracy has occurred appropriately oh
are we talking about the association of
counties sure okay so with the
association of counties my legislative
group is about 90 people we meet every
Friday afternoon to talk about
legislation uh and then it goes to the
executive committee if we have a piece
of legislation that multip you know one
or another county is opposed to and
others are in favor of we do not lob it
we don't he ends off if they want to
come up and they want to lobby for
something that's up to them but we do as
an association do not get
involved
good other
questions and Pearson thank you Mr chair
just for just for clarification on what
you just said so so the action that the
association of counties takes um when it
does Lobby is on actions that the the
board goes through the process of coming
out unanimous correct okay okay thank
you um one final question that I have um
are the are the individual counties also
members of um New Hampshire Municipal
Association the only County I'm aware of
that is an affiliate member is suvin
County that's the only County and I
think that then they had get no advocacy
from nhma it's basically for legal
assistance and things like that but they
nhma does not Lobby for any County okay
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you further question seeing none
thank you
um the man with uh the Teflon
suit
um thank
you please enter and sign in please um
here to oppose the bill from nhma
thank you Mr chair n gra for the
municipal Association as I hope you all
understand from Context we oppose this
legislation um one of the services we
provide our members is when they care
deeply about legislation we do deliver
those letters to committees uh
regardless of what our policy positions
are on those letters as you'll see from
the folders that you are now passing
around there are 35 letters from Members
35 different members all of whom were
opposed to this legislation um I do have
one small correction to my uh my letter
that's in there which is that I listed
32 but I got three more yesterday so we
have small towns like Fremont large ones
like londonairy you''ve heard from from
numerous other ones today um but my
letter does summarize most of those it
doesn't have Auburn Salem or Swansea
because I received those
yesterday um seems like the committee
had a number of questions um I guess the
first point I really want to make is
that the bill in front of you has some
pretty vague language in it um with
respect to the chair we have discussed
the bill language uh with the four
attorneys in our office and we all agree
that it is contrary to 155 if we were to
provide legal advice to any member
calling us about whether they could
testify in their official capacity we
would warn them that they may in fact be
subject to criminal penalty
um there are additional concerns we have
as well um there is a provision in there
about being allowed to provide
information um I don't think I need to
say this but I'm going to anyway which
is that it should be pretty clear based
on the testimony you've already received
today that we're opposed to this bill
even if I were never to say opposed and
I got up and just listed a bunch of
things I don't like about it it's pretty
clear we're opposed to the bill same
thing if we had a bill that we liked get
up and say three things about it that I
like again we would like that bill to
pass the word oppose or support is not
in our view magical it's actually the
context of the conversation that
occurs and that's what we would be
obviously concerned about um and you
know there has been some talk today
about uh about our organization and how
it functions I just want to be clear
that we're a voluntary nonprofit
nonpartisan
organization we have a policy setting
conference that I believe Mr Karen
described uh very accurately um that
policy setting conference is done with
our members they tell us what they want
us to Advocate on support oppose it
occurs every two years while all of you
are knocking on doors for re-election um
our members are meeting to decide what
we should advocate for over the next
two-year period and then based on that
um we we go out and we support bills or
oppose bills um we also obviously track
what members like and sometimes members
request things that we're not sure uh
how they fit under our policy positions
so just to give you an example um
there's a there were one member
requested this year a change to the
groundwater withdrawal processes that
Bill's been heard later today in
resources and wreck um we actually had
to go to our board for further Direction
because we knew that was going to impact
another member and we wanted wanted to
make sure that we weren't going to
advocate for something that was harm to
uh another
municipality um I think the committee's
also had some questions on 155 and um
segregation of funds uh that applies to
lobbyists we do follow the law as it
exists now um and I guess the last point
I really want to make but I'm certainly
happy to take questions is that uh
actually two other points I'm sorry um
there have been a number of questions
about fiscal notes and how those happen
um honestly that question is best
reserved for the legislative budget
assistant um from my perspective what
happens is we sometimes receive requests
for information from the legislative
budget assistant yes it does have
information that I'm not allowed to
disclose which may or may not be a draft
of a bill um but I'm thoroughly warned
I'm not allowed to disclose that and
what they're interested in is any
information we can provide on financial
impacts whether that's going to increase
revenues whether that's decreased
revenues whatever that is it's the
instructions are very strict that you're
not supposed to Advocate on that I
understand that obviously if there is a
fiscal note written that could be
advocacy they uh they have their own
internal processes I have zero control
over what they ask me for information
for if any state agency asks me for
information whether it's the LBA whether
it's the es whether it's you know uh do
whoever it is and I have that
information or I can direct them
correctly just as I would do for any
legislator I will direct you to that um
that's that's what I do if you'd like to
change that process and remove us from
that process that's totally up to you
that's not something we do that's
internal to LBA and what they do um I
just ask that you talk to them about it
um and the last point is um we do think
that it's a fundamental right to speak
to the government and we think that it's
really important that uh that our
members are able to um petition the
government and they use us as
essentially the microphone for that um
or the megaphone for that we uh we we do
what they ask us to do and um we come
before you with their positions whatever
those may
be and realistically uh you know they
can't always make it here and it's
frankly not always a good use of
taxpayer money to pay for three
different elected officials from three
different towns to come here when they
could just send me instead
um it's just cheaper for everybody um
and so we we do oppose this bill um you
know I think that the the government
does have a right to speak um and that's
what we we support we believe that's
constitutional we believe that's a
fundamental right under the
Constitution happy to take questions
thank you for your question uh for your
testimony um rep walls have a question I
hope you can hear
me sorry um I have a couple of questions
um municipalities can decide whether or
not to participate as members of nhma
correct correct and we've had in the
past decade I think it is Salem and um I
believe the other one was marac were're
not members for a period of time um
there was a shift in our policies based
on our member input and they decided to
rejoin follow up thank you and
municipalities can contact you if they
don't agree with legislation absolutely
as I said at the beginning you know we
if they don't like legislation but they
want us to deliver a letter and say Hey
you know we know nhma is opposed but we
support it or vice versa we do that
that's a service we provide final
question final question how often do you
hear from commun entities who are
unhappy with what nhma is
representing not very frequently because
of our policy setting process that they
they're all involved in um typically
what happens if they have a bill that
they're very passionate about um so I'll
throw the town of Conway under the bus
here the town of Conway is very
passionate about doing something with
Hotel occupancy fees that we don't have
a specific policy position on that we
advise them to participate in the next
uh this upcoming policy process to see
if you know that's something that they
could help use us for and we could we
could do more uh advocacy on and they
are going to participate in that so
thank you representative
perer hello thank you for being here um
in the packet that you passed out I see
there's a letter from the town of
Fremont that opposes this bill and and
CC to
representative yella the last uh
paragraph of the letter States HB 1479
threatens the core concept of local
control can you do you have any thing
that you could elaborate about that
absolutely the uh as this committee has
heard extensively today the decision to
join or not join nhma or any other
organization that then comes here and
speaks to all of you is something that's
decided the local level through the
transparent budget process uh any voter
in any municipality has the option to
work through that process to say hey I
don't want our town to be a member of
this organization and and as I've given
you examples they've done that in the
past because they have not agreed um and
so by taking that that voice away from
government um by taking that away from
the people you know that loses the
opportunity to have people like me come
here and say hey if you pass this
legislation there's going to be some
sort of impact on your your uh the
taxpayers of your town is what we talk
about a lot we talk about you know we
want state aid we want additional money
or if this legislation might have some
sort of requirement requires towns to do
something it's going to cost a million
dollars a town or whatever it is we we
point that
out uh I just want to I should have done
this earlier um we are to ask clarifying
questions
um rather than
um well I'll just leave it at that um
rep
costable thank you thank you Mr chair
and uh thank you for taking my question
so I we've had conflicting information
I've had both in public here today in
this testimony and privately have been
told that this is not about the
information or the general services that
you guys provide that they they they
like but they don't want to the towns
may not want to participate in the
lobbying efforts and that there are um
the people Town's people can go to their
meetings and pull out the funding but
the the way I'm understanding it is that
this is uh there's no mechanism to pull
out lobbying efforts especially if
you're not segregating what what you're
spending on lobbying or not so is there
a process to be a part of your
Association and not pay for lobbying
efforts so our dues are calculated based
on population and assessed value and
there's a formula for that um and it's
just you either pay to join or you don't
join that's that's the way it works um
if you don't have to join um and
certainly again we have an open process
that members participate in to tell us
what to advocate for so um that's that's
how it
works follow up thank you Mr chair um
are you opposed to segregating Lobby
funds is is is the lobbying effort
compared to say what what a lot of the
uh local select board and then they they
really like the the the lawyer inputs on
on some of the stuff and that that has
nothing to do with specific bills and um
is is are you saying that it's
essential to come here and Lobby on
bills as part of your Association like
are you completely opposed to separating
a Lobby fund and what gets paid towards
lobbying and then having it something
separate so here's how why we can't do
that because I don't know if you guys
are going to run on time or not and so
if I'm supposed to keep track of my
hours as I do and re-report that to the
Secretary of State's office and that's
available I don't know how much of my
salary to Bill to lobbying versus the
other four jobs that I have providing
legal advice doing trains Etc I only
know that after the fact so I don't know
in January June 15th comes am I going to
spend 600 hours here I'm going to spend
700 hours here how much time am I going
to spend here and unfortunately this
isn't a shift job I mean if everything
ran on time I'd love to come in talk for
15 minutes build that out and leave that
would be really easy we could figure
that out but that's not the way this
works I have to sit here for as long as
these hearings take so I can come up and
answer questions and provide the
information I can provide um and at we
do the quarterly reports um we do
everything else so you see that in
retrospect we we just can't predict how
long it's going to take we can't predict
how many bills are going to affect
municip alties that we to spend time on
um so I I just can't do
that representative
lter thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question could you explain to
me a circumstance where it would be a
appropriate for every town in a county
to belong to your
organization through dues but also the
county as a whole belongs to that same
organiz ganization so the taxpayers are
paying twice can you explain why that
would be a appropriate circumstance so
we have both our full memberships which
are cities and towns and then we have
associate memberships which are counties
Village districts um we provide
different services so we don't advoc we
only Advocate on behalf of cities and
towns we do not Advocate on behalf of
counties or Village districts um we but
what the associate membership gets them
is they can come to our trainings we do
a lot of trainings that overlap with
kind of the same laws that counties need
and the counties Association doesn't
necessarily do the same type of
trainings but for example in Coos County
um there number of
um uh I don't remember the name of but
there's there's the county planning that
uh planning board that occurs up there
so they need to know what the land use
statutes are we provide that training it
doesn't really make sense for the
County's associ Association to provide
that as much because we do that with
with 234 cities and towns so different
Services mostly the training side of
things is what they're what they're
accessing and again that's all voluntary
so you could always choose not to have
your county join if that's what you're
interested
in followup followup question thank you
uh it's actually not a followup to this
but it's a followup to something you
said a little while ago um in your
testimony you said something to the
effect I want to make sure I understand
your position about uh the government
having free speech and I I don't think
you intended to mean that the
constitution protects a government's
right to free speech because it does not
provide for that as you're probably well
aware well I think there's a right to
petition the government and I think that
you know when a group of people get
together they inform an organization and
that organization can petition the
government on behalf of those people uh
and I think that's a fundamental right
that's enshrined in the First
Amendment
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair
um do you know what the total revenues
are for
nhna not off the top of my head but I
could get that information for you thank
you for a followup yes uh do you know
what the total revenues do you oh first
of all do you get other revenues besides
the city and towns and counties do you
get any private revenues any other
revenues from Big corporations or
anything else like that or corporations
General anything so our our entire
Revenue the vast majority of it is
membership dues and then local officials
come to our training some of those they
have to pay for some of those are free
those paid ones are obviously also paid
for by the cities and towns um and then
we sometimes have uh sponsorships of
trainings in order to offset some of the
costs so like our annual conference we
have I don't know like four different
law firms and and some other entities
that sponsor that and they get little
booths um and kind of standard stuff I
don't know what the breakdown is but I
can follow up please yep yeah just for
clarity um I'm just wondering do you get
other monies from outside of government
how's
that only in the context I just gave you
like like a law firm can't just give us
a check for $1,000 we would not do that
that's not they have to have some
relationship to what we're doing
representative
payer okay I'm going to need your help
if that if this is okay for me to ask
I'll be listening
okay can you I'm just curious can you
give a little bit of information about
your background of your education to
work in New Hampshire M Association sure
so I'm an attorney I was originally
hired to work in the legal services side
of things and I was not previously a
municipal attorney I was actually a a
prosecutor for uh several small towns um
so I'm an attorney uh so I have a a law
degree um learned Municipal laot uh
worked with cities and towns to train
them over the few years and then uh my
the person who had this role before me
he retired and the position opened up
and I was selected how many years have
you been doing this work as an
attorney like how many years have I been
an attorney I'm sorry many I have been
an attorney for I think 11 years now 12
2013 is when I was sworn to the party
sorry low blood sugar sorry M know what
that's like rap
costable thank you Mr chair and thank
you again for taking my question can you
um shed some light on how the
association comes to decisions um based
on membership keeping so um and with
with in the context of um representative
next to me lives in a large town town
I'm in a very small town uh so the the
money coming in is is
disproportionate um so how do you
balance the let's say rural
municipalities versus the cities where
the cities are paying far much far
greater to to the association than say
the rural how do you protect the rural
municipalities sure so thank you for the
question we're obligated to represent
everyone to the best of our ability so
when there are uh clear divide so for
example in the education debate whether
there's donor towns or not donor towns
that's something we can't get involved
in because it it divides municipalities
so we try as much as possible to make
sure and as I gave you the example
earlier with the uh brwater withdrawal
processes we had to go back to our board
for that because we said look the the
context in which this came up was um one
town was concerned because the town next
door was drawing was drilling a large
well
we don't know whether that's going to
cause some sort of conflict we can't be
in a position of pitting Town against
Town um so we had to talk with our board
to see what our position would be on
that bill if any um and so we try to
make sure that when there's that
conflict we we don't get involved in
those because that's we need to
represent everyone to the best of our
ability my turn um so my my first
question is is there somewhere we can go
um or can you provide for us a list of
all of your clients
Beyond um the cities and towns I don't
have any clients other than cities and
towns you mean like well associate
members and everything yeah I I can
follow up with you on that yes that' be
great
um then I have a question of um I asked
the prime sponsor earlier and I would
like your opin opinion um on the idea of
whether this legislation and
maybe um some of the existing
legislation might be in a in incorrectly
placed within the lobbyist section
rather than in the cities and towns and
what money can be spent on U within that
cities and town
section I'm not sure I follow I'm sorry
Mr CH so so um the idea that money can
only be it in here there are
specifications of where money can uh
what state funds can be done with in
order to purchase lobbying
Services we had an example earlier where
it may be that um the lobbying firm may
not have any idea where the funding is
coming from to pay their services so I'm
asking whether um for purposes of
location maybe this is in the the weeds
but should um the the exemptions or the
exceptions of of what can be purchased
with state or local funds should that be
in the section on cities and towns not
in the section on
lobbyists well chapter 15 applies to
lobbyists which would apply to me does
not apply to cities and towns so if
you're contemplating a different change
as to what Authority cities and towns
have that may be appropriate somewhere
else versus what my role is right okay
um won't Bel labor that
um I think I you you answered the
question about whether um
funding could be withheld from a city or
town if they chose not to have lobbying
services that that and you said that
that could not be done correct correct
um and and the last question I have is
the the formula that you have for um for
charging
premium uh how is it that um um pick two
towns London Derry and meramac um are
they aren't there aren't there services
that they're receiving the same um
within regardless of their their
population are
um is it not true that um their ability
to ask you legal questions or do
training or any of those things is the
same regardless of their Town population
so our dues are calculated on population
and assessed value
obviously it pertains to our budget
because you have to pay for staff so if
all towns were to pay the same amount as
Freedom paid we probably wouldn't be
able to have a staff because that's just
not a very high number um so that budget
is set by our board of directors which
is comprised of local officials so
they're the ones Who oversee that if you
want more information about how that
process works and everything I can
certainly ask my executive director to
follow up are all the associate members
the same rate or are they also by that
formula I don't know that off the top of
my head I do know Village districts used
to be a set rate of I think 500 a year I
don't know if that's true for counties
and I'm not sure if that has changed
okay but I will follow up with that
information I'm told it's in there um
anybody up representative mcarter real
quick I thank you Mr chair um so are you
suggesting that a town say like dairy or
London Dairy larger population uh higher
property
values um and then compare us into a
town like Freedom new Hamp sure um are
they able to access the same level of
service do they get prioritized because
they pay a higher dues or everybody gets
access to the same information or
resources that your organization uh
provides regardless of population or
dues we don't change like everybody can
call our Legal Services we just have our
internal you know how you process these
which we try to turn around you know
answers to questions for General legal
advice within 24
hours great um I think we're all set uh
appreciate your thank you your patience
uh with us um with that I have no other
pin cards um I'm closing the hearing on
um just
for committee purposes um So the plan is
um we have cancelled the exec session
for this afternoon
uh we did that first off uh the thought
process is um we're going to try to move
everything that we didn't do today on
the exec session um well obviously into
the future but most of them would be um
next
Wednesday um so watch your calendars um
I will also if anything changes on any
of that I will try to speak to you
tomorrow in session represent sellers is
there a preference on morning or
afternoon on Ah that's right we didn't
really uh we we didn't we we seem to
have a um you don't particularly care
for mornings
right
um we do we do have a
uh more to come I
I the ranking member and I will have to
have a conversation about it I think but
we'll do our best um to accommodate
everyone no
lobbying no influencing my vote
um all right uh thanks everybody um
appreciate
it